Have I been [music] called much worse than a despot? So, it's
not it's not that insulting.
Maybe I think he'll change his mind after we get to working together.
Yes, please. [laughter] >> Trump, dude, Trump's like, "Yeah,
it's water off a duck's back." Listen, people call me worse things
than that all the
Let's just pick one. Let's just pick one. Let's do Zoron and
Trump.
>> [__] it. We got a Zoron Trump meeting. Did
I pick the lowest resolution version of this meeting? >> Well,
thank you. >> I did. I did. Oh, look at the video I got
and the actual video.
>> The video I got and then the actual video.
What the [__] >> But I just want to congratulate.
I think you're going to have hopefully a really great mayor.
The better he does, the happier I am. I will say it. There's
no
>> just crazy stuff. Crazy stuff from Trump here. Okay.
If prices come down, that'll be good for all Americans. No way.
I thought that was like the point of his campaign, but he's saying
it here, so it must not have been that obvious to people, I guess.
Absolutely wild. >> Difference in party. There's no difference
in anything. And we're going to be helping him uh to make everybody's
dream come true, having a strong and very safe New York. And
congratulations, Mr. Mayor. >> Thank you, Mr. President.
>> Thank you. >> I appreciate it. Please. I appreciated
the the meeting with the president and as he said it was a productive
meeting focused on a place of shared admiration and love which
is New York City and the need to deliver affordability to New
Yorkers the 8 and a2 million people who call our city their home
who are struggling to afford life in the most expensive city
in the United States of America. We spoke about rent. We spoke
about groceries. We spoke about utilities. We spoke about the
different ways in which people are being pushed out. And I appreciated
the time with the president. I appreciated the conversation.
and I look forward to working together to deliver.
>> People never realize this, but like Trump totally is.
He would totally be susceptible to socialism on like every level.
Or maybe people do talk about it, but I I fully believe if you
just went to him were like, "Yeah, people are like getting squeezed
on groceries." And we think if the government runs one of the
grocery stores, then that sort of puts a a price floor there.
Like the grocery store will have a put a floor on prices or sorry,
a ceiling on prices. a ceiling, not a floor, a ceiling on prices.
And I think that's just a good concept. And Trump would go, "Yeah,
that makes some sense to me." Yeah, that I think that makes sense,
right? He's got no principled connection to like economic conservative
economic conservatism. He's got nothing like that, right? No
conser no real conservative politics there >> that affordability
for New Yorkers.
>> Thank you very much. Any questions,
>> President Trump, Stephen Nelson from the New York Post.
I had a question for you and then also one for Maryland. uh for
you referred to Mr. Maldani as a communist. Can you describe
why you feel that way? And also, will you do anything that's
enough to stop him from arresting Prime Minister Netanyahu if
he visits New York? >> Well, we didn't discuss your second
>> Yeah, it's exactly it. Posting online like you could
totally just frame this in in a way Trump understands. He would
love it. Trump has glazed Bernie a bit in the past. Makes sense
that he also likes Zoron. He's Bernie with way more charisma.
That's not true. Bernie has infinitely more charisma than Bernie
has infinitely more charisma than Zoron. I'm sorry. I know people
like Zoron. Zoron seems fine to me. Comparing him to Bernie is
insane. Who were his opponents? His opponents were the disgraced
former governor of the state who couldn't win the primary against
him and
Eric Adams, the disgraced former mayor of New York City. Like,
he had totally disgraced opponents. He had nothing going against
him at all. I'm sorry. He seems like fine, but I He just doesn't
have [snorts] He doesn't have the same thing going on that Bernie
does. I'm sorry. He does not. He's not even I don't even know
that I'd put him above AOC.
And Bernie is like four steps ahead of AOC. You're never going
to get this across to lefties that are completely smitten with
Mum Donnie. I I don't understand how that seems so insulting
to me that you compare him to Bernie. Bernie's like so much better
than this guy. He's so much more compelling. part of the question
and on your first part I mean he's got views a little out there
but who knows I mean we're going to see what works or he's going
to change also we all change I changed a lot changed a lot from
when I first came to office it's now quite a while ago it's quite
a while my first term was great we had a the greatest economy
in the history of our country and we're doing even better now
we're doing much better now than we did even in the first term
and I can tell you some of my views have changed and we we discussions
on some things. I'm not going to discuss what they were, but
uh that I feel very confident that he could do a very good job.
I think I think he's going to be I think he is going to surprise
some conservative people actually and some very liberal people.
He won't surprise him because they already like him. >> And
Mr.
It sounds like you had a productive discussion, but just basically
>> Trump's so funny that like
I I don't know how you walk this line cuz basically when you're
some left-leaning politician, everybody wants you to like super
attack Trump, right? But if you're just nice to him in person,
he'll like give you the benefit of the doubt forever. Basically,
like with with Mark Carney, every time Mark Carney goes and talks
to Trump, he's just like, "Yes, you're very intelligent. You're
going to bring the prices down. You're going to do everything
right." And Trump's like, "No more tariffs." And then Mark Carney
goes back to Canada. And then Trump gets mad about something.
He goes, "Tariffs again." And then Mark Carney comes down and
goes, "Yeah, you're going to get prices down. You're like making
America great again. You're awesome." And Trump's like, "No more
tariffs. Canada's awesome." It's so like what do you want your
politician to do? It's like, do you want them to stand on principle
and and have Trump like focus his eye on New York City and totally
like make life hell for everybody there? Or do you just want
him to like sort of forget you exist? you go be nice in person
and then you he forgets you exist and then you can move on. Which
one do you want? Cuz I understand the the like want to to commit
to Yeah. this guy even in person. But [laughter] I don't know,
man. If I elect somebody, I maybe want them to like think about
a little bit. Okay, just think about it. People online, people
on the internet, they can stand up business. Okay, this guy who's
got to go and talk to him in person, maybe you want him to come
out just a little bit. You know, you've heard President Trump
as a desperate who betrayed [clears throat] the country. You
said it would be his worst nightmare and accused him of having
a fascist agenda. Um, are you claiming to retract any his remarks
in order to improve the >> Hey, you uh you called Donald
Trump a fascist. You called you called Mr. Trump a Bro, why you
why you got to hit me with my quotes like that, bro? Why you
got why you got to hit me with that my quotes like that, bro?
What the
[laughter] I'm I'm talking this right
It's like you're sitting at like the the lunch table in middle
school and somebody comes up and is like, "Hey, why are you guys
eating lunch together? Weren't you talking [__] about
this guy the other day? Weren't you talking
Uh, Zoron's got to be sitting here like, "Listen, if I'm a communist,
this guy's If you can call me a communist, this guy I can call
him. I can call him Paul Pot. I can call him Paul Pot was a fascist,
right? I forget. I can call him whoever the [__]
I want. Mussolini. Hey, he's definitely a fascist if I'm a communist.
>> I think both President Trump and I, we are very clear
about our positions and our views. And what I really appreciate
about the president is the meeting that we had focused not on
places of disagreement, which there are many, and also focused
on >> wait, he totally >> the shared purpose that
we have in serving New Yorkers. And frankly, that is something
that could transform the lives of the 8 and 12 million people
who are currently struggling under a cost of living crisis with
one in four living in poverty. That's That's a good answer though.
That's a really good Paul Pot was a commie. God damn it.
Who am I think Oh, I'm thinking of Pinocha. Pino is who? >> And
the meeting came back again and again to what it could look like
to lift those New Yorkers out of struggle and start to deliver
them a city that they could do more than just struggle to afford
it, but actually start to live in >> And I've been called
much worse than a despot. So, it's not it's not that insulting.
[laughter] Maybe I think he'll change his mind after we get to
working together. Yes, please.
>> Trump. Dude, Trump's like, "Yeah, it was water off a
duck's back." Listen, people call me worse things than that all
the
>> I would like to ask you a question about the Middle
East regarding you said that in Lebanon is not in a good position
and Lebanon now is the final unresolved after Gaza and Syria.
Given your
>> I can't hear the questions very well.
Lebanon and what is your next move to push toward disarm the
disarm? >> Sure. Well, we are
>> Israel Palestine question. It sounds like I heard Lebanon
in there. I think >> total disarmament of
frankly everybody else and we actually have peace in the Middle
East as you know the king of Saudi Arabia just left yesterday.
We had >> Oh, did did MBS and Trump do a thing like this?
I feel like somehow I feel like I would want to watch that really
badly if NBS and Trump did like a little sit down with the media
like this. But would NBS even do that? NBS like doesn't do that,
right? He wouldn't. That that would basically be like a public
interview. I think he's mostly private.
they did. Oh, we might have to check out the NBS stuff then.
I bet it was
Yeah, I bet it was. But for some reason, I just wonder what that
relationship's like. Because in my mind, although I can't prove
it, I feel like NBS is like privately funding a lot of this government
somehow, right? Through like the through the thing with Kushner,
I feel like somehow he's funneling money into this camp into
this administration into Trump directly.
So, I just wonder how Trump would would react to questions there.
>> Some great meetings and he's uh made a contribution
toward the United States of a trillion dollars. We have now over
20 trillion dollars coming in. No country has ever had anything
like that. Not even close. If you go to two trillion or one trillion,
it's a lot. We have 20 or 21 trillion dollars. U I think that
uh Hezbollah
has been a problem. And Lebanon, big problem. We're working with
Lebanon. We're working with everybody in the Middle East. That's
another thing I think we have in common. We want to see peace
in the Middle East. And we actually have now for the first time
peace in the Middle East after 3,000 years. And now we're going
to refine it. And I think you're going to see some very positive
things happen.
30 minutes. >> Oh, sure. Oh, I would I would do that. Absolutely.
And if the mayor would like to be here for that meeting cuz I
know he feels very strongly. I think you feel very very strongly
about peace in the Middle East. I think >> we we we desperately
want it. And that's something that I shared with the president
that when I spoke to New Yorkers who had voted for the president
last November on Hillside Avenue in Fortm Road, I asked them
why. I heard again and again two major reasons. One was that
they wanted an end to forever wars. They wanted an end to the
taxpayer dollars we had funding violations of human rights. And
they wanted to address the cost of living crisis and I appreciated
the chance to discuss both of those things. >> You said
a lot of my voters actually voted for him and one >> and
I'm okay with that. >> One in 10. One in 10's not a lot.
A lot of my voters voted for him. One in 10. Uh that's that's
funny. I feel like I feel like he's suddenly saying not that
many. No, not that many actually. No, no, I don't know about
that. One in 10. Okay, I don't know about that. >> I'll
do that. I'll sign it. Give it to me. I'll sign it in a minute.
That's pretty good. >> Mr. President,
he's trying to send federal troops to New York City. You both
have differences when it comes to >> Yeah. You said that
like he was going to be like a communist dictator over New York
City and you're going to have to send troops to take care of
that. What happened? Now you guys are smiling, laughing. Seems
like you guys are all bark no bite on this one, right? I What?
Why did you say that? Why did you say that this guy was going
to like be hanging, you know, hanging people from Wall Street
off the Empire State Building? Why did you say that, >> Donald?
New York City
called ICE on road government entity. I wonder how you reconcile
your differences on both of those issues. >> Well, I think
we're going to work them out. And I think that uh if we have
known murderers and known drug dealers and some very bad people,
you know, we want to get them out. And the mayor wants to have
uh pe we discussed this at great length actually, maybe more
than anything else. Uh he wants to have a safe New York. Ultimately,
a safe New York is going to be a great New York. If it's not
safe, no matter how well we do with pricing and with uh anything
else, we can talk about anything you want.
Oh, Rodmus, thank you very much for the individual sub. Appreciate
it, buddy. >> You don't have
>> So, basically,
I I don't even know. This is very strange to me cuz
you called ICE a rogue government entity and Trump Trump just
gives infinite charity here. Trump's just like, "You know what?
It's fine. We'll figure it out. It's fine. We'll figure it out."
I think there's just a lot of a lot of acknowledgement here that
there's a ton of posturing that went on before this election
and realistically they know none of it was true and they're just
accepting reality now. It's like no no we know that this guy
isn't actually a socialist. We know that he's not a communist.
We just we're going to we're going to make it work. Okay, we're
going to make it work.
If it is one in 10 Republicans, that could be quite a big swing
in the general, right? It's like one in 10 New York City Trump
voters or something, right? which like that's different than
That's that's New York City Trump voters. I'm guessing that if
you go to any state outside of New York and California that those
people vote blue no matter who, right?
Like realistically their politics for being, you know, Republicans
in New York is very
>> safe streets. It's not going to be a success. So we're
going to work together. We're going to make sure that if there
horrible people there, we want to get them out. I think he wants
to get them out. maybe more than I do. So, we'll work together.
We discussed it at great length. Yes, please. >> Yeah.
Two questions coming. One for you, Mr. President, BBC in a second.
But first of all, to the mayor, you're both from different parts
of the political perspective. You're both populist and I just
wonder to what extent
the president's campaign style, his techniques, his social media
use, his part of your campaign. >> Well, oh,
finally somewhere they could come together. Hey, you like social
media? He likes social media. Some say he's the first politician
who really effectively utilized social media. What do you think
about that? Did you take some of his >> I actually told
the president that, you know, so much of the focus of our campaign
has been on the cost of living crisis. And when we asked those
New Yorkers who had voted for the president when we saw an increase
in his numbers in New York City that came back to the same issue,
cost of living, cost of living, cost of living. and they spoke
about the cost of groceries, the cost of rent, the cost of coned,
the cost of child care. And too often politicians are looking
to lecture to New Yorkers what they should care about as opposed
to listen. And when we spoke to those voters who voted for President
Trump, we heard them speak about cost of living, we focus on
that same cost of living. And that's where I am really looking
forward to delivering for New Yorkers in partnership with the
president on the affordability agenda. [clears throat] That makes
sense. >> And I think we have >> That's a good answer.
That's one of the I understand this guy's got to have something
going for him. I'll be honest, every time I watch something where
he's speaking, he kind of sounds like a goober to me. He kind
of he kind of sucks most of the time I've seen him speak. Like
he's not even close to good. That was way better. It's just like,
hey, we politicians get used to lecturing on what you should
care about. We just listened. Affordability. Affordability crosses
party lines. Okay. >> We have to work a little bit. We
talked about Khan Edison. We have to work a little bit on getting
the prices because, you know, we've gotten fuel prices way down,
but it hasn't shown up in Con Edison
and we're going to have to talk to them. You know, if if we're
saying sending them fuel at a much lower price than it was a
year ago, which is true, uh we have to get Con Edison to start
lowering their rates.
>> And last week you told me you were completely ahead
of your plans
$5 billion. You speak to Prime Minister Star as well.
>> well, we get along very well with uh the prime minister.
We made a deal with UK. I like him. He's a fine person. And you
know, I think they have some big energy problems. You know, they've
got windmills all over the place. They're going to have to start
using >> Maybe because you're young, this is new to you.
But I've heard these promises for decades from our elected officials.
Lol. Nothing will change.
Okay. I mean,
probably it's difficult to change things. Yeah. I I don't know.
What? What do you suggest, Pytos?
Do we start firebombing stuff or do we just give up and go hide
in a hole? I'm not sure which one.
I I get it.
There's only like so long being the edgy like I don't nothing
will happen guy like pays off for you. Just do that bit all the
time.
You know, you know, sometimes you just got to be like, "Oh, well,
I hope this will be something better."
I or not. I mean, or just I can't say what you like what it if
that's true and nothing will ever change and nothing can change
and everything's over then I mean
there's only one way out at that point and I can't talk about
it. So >> other methods because their energy is out of
control talking about in the UK it's out of control
and he's got that problem. He's got a big immigration problem
as you know and he's got a big energy problem and we talk about
he's a good man. Prime Minister is a good man.
>> I haven't spoken this week.
>> Have you spoken to President
President Zilinski about your plan?
>> Uh I've spoken with their people. We have a plan. It's
horrible what's happening. It's a war that should have never
happened. It would have never happened if I was president. And
it's a shame. And I thought they should have acted quicker. But
it's a cold winter and a lot of the uh a lot of the you talk
about utilities but a lot of the big uh energy producing plants
have been under attack to put it mildly to put it nicely. Uh
yeah, we have a a way of getting peace or we think we have a
way of getting peace. He's going to have to approve it. This
is so sad. So many people, you know, last month they lost 25,000
soldiers.
This is something we haven't seen anything like this since the
Second World War. And they're averaging six or 7 thousand a week.
>> Wait,
weren't some of like the So the Weren't some of those Southeast
Asian wars like really extremely bloody for one of the sides?
What about like Kissinger firebombing was it Cambodia?
I feel like feel like there's been some some stuff that's been
pretty bad since World War II >> between the two of them
dead soldiers. And it goes on and on and I think they're getting
reasonably close, but it's I don't want to predict. I would have
said that would have been one of my early ones. I did eight peace
deals of countries including in India, Pakistan. Uh you could
even go in fact they're coming here in a week or two. Uh go to
the Congo and Rwanda. That was one 10 million people dead and
we worked something out on that. But so many and the one I thought
would have been for me because I have a very good relationship
with President Putin. I thought that would have been maybe quicker,
but it's it does take two to tango and now [clears throat] uh
you just see all the death and you know it doesn't affect us
other than the fact that we don't want to see all those people
that really it's on the other side of the ocean. It's a war that
should have never happened. It did happen. I blame the person
also sitting right behind this desk. This is a war that should
have never happened and it wouldn't have happened if I were president.
But we're trying to save a >> Oh, different guys sitting
behind that >> They're losing. They're losing 25. Think
of that.
Smer is a complete [__] destroying the UK. I do think
at some point I might have to get into UK politics. I talked
to Beckett the other night. He was telling me about UK politics.
Some stuff going on there. I don't know, man. It see there's
some pretty crazy apparently the Reform Party in the UK is like
seemingly going to just totally sweep their next election.
And like reform, he said reform might be worse than MAGA, like
possibly.
and that it's
it's going to be rough. Doesn't Queman kind of like Star Yeah,
Queman is super lip pill and Quean probably hates everything
going on in his country. After talking to Becket about this,
it seems like oh now I understand why Queen covers UK politics.
He's probably really that like British MAGA is
is going crazy. Becket has some weird allegations apparently.
What?
Like what?
Uh I don't know what that is. you tell me about it if you want.
I have no idea what the that is. Never heard about >> 5,000
lives over the last short period of time. That's Ukrainian and
Russian. And uh it's a shame.
>> I want to ask the mayor elect about a house resolution
just passed overwhelmingly to condemn socialism including with
86 Democrats. All of
>> someone lied and said he had with
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I understand. I understand that you guys
can meme on the star, but that's not like an allegation. That's
not like that's not malf
I'm just >> leadership and the minority leader from Jeff
despite his endorsement of you. What's your reaction to that?
I have to >> No, it's not an allegation. It's just his
partner at the time. Well, you guys are weird. You guys are Okay,
listen.
I'm so I see why Stardust hates me, by the way. It's not even
me. It's my audience. Okay, that's why Stardust hates me because
of the my audience does and says it's [__] crazy.
All right, you guys are sick. You guys are very rude. You guys
are very disgusting. Okay, what the be honest with you, I focus
very little on resolutions. Frankly, I've been focusing
>> I understand. I think the focus is on the work at hand.
I can tell you I am someone who is a democratic socialist. I've
been very open about that and I know there might be differences
about ideology but the place of agreement is the work that needs
to be done to make New York City affordable. That's what I look
forward to. >> And I want to clarify that your answer to
Stephen Nelson. He asked about your comment calling the president
a fascist. Um and your answer was
President Trump and I have been clear about our positions and
our views. >> Are you affirming that you think President
Trump is a fascist? >> I've spoken about >> That's
okay. You can just say >> Hold on. I was not watching I
was not watching the faces there, but Jesus
>> Both President Trump and I have been clear about our
positions and our views. >> Are you affirming that you
think President Trump is the faction? >> He's He knows
where it's going. Zoron, you really hit me. You hit me with this
one again. I already answered this once. You hit me with this
again.
>> I've spoken about >> That's okay. You can just
say
it's easier.
>> No, no, no. Just call me a fascist and we'll move on.
Just They're going to keep asking. They're going to keep asking.
Just say I'm a fascist so we can move on. Thank you.
[laughter] You can say it. No, you can say it. Call me. Okay.
Go ahead. Go
I've been watching this Fentes kid. Apparently, we love So, go
ahead. Call me. Okay. Apparently, the young people, they love
who knew.
I'll keep Listen, just go ahead. >> I've spoken about >> That's
okay. You can just say >> okay it's easier
it's easier than explaining a pedal.
He just did he just add a boy Zoron? Zoron says yes and then
and then Trump goes add a boy.
>> It's easier than explaining it. I don't >> Did
he just add a boy him?
>> I wanted to ask you also
about this Ukraine plan.
>> He said I don't mind. Oh, he said I don't mind. Okay.
I don't mind. While he was doing the adab boy slab. I got it.
I got it. I got it.
>> All right. We need to break this down one more time.
than explaining it. I don't mind.
>> Ah, it's easier than explaining it. I don't mind. I
don't mind. And he taps him. Okay.
Which is funny because to me that actually speaks to what I think
would be a private interaction between these two where Trump
maybe asked or maybe somebody around Trump asked like, "Hey,
didn't you call this guy a fascist?" And maybe Zoron went and
explained like what he means by that, how he sees it, right?
and went, "You know, I don't think you're evil, but but here's
what I mean when I say that." And so he goes, "Now Trump goes,
h it's easier than explaining why you said it. Just say yes.
Just say you you mean it." >> I wanted to ask you also
about this Ukraine plan. President Zullinsky said today that
his country would risk either giving up a partner or giving up
its dignity. There's been criticism that this deal >> Do
you mean he doesn't like it? >> It's unclear. He was sort
of >> he'll have to like it and if he doesn't like it then,
you know, they should just keep fighting. I guess you know the
>> suggestion that you made though was that if he doesn't
accept it that the US would pull back its support for Ukraine.
>> Well, at some point he's going to have to accept something.
You know, he hasn't accepted. You remember right in the Oval
Office not so long ago,
uh I said, "You don't have the cards.
Don't forget I inherit
>> Oh, this is an interesting point." Yeah.
just go ahead and call me a fascist. I to some extent he doesn't
care about Zoron doing it. He probably cares about people doing
it at large. But it is it undermines the whole point a little
bit that oh calling someone a fascist means you can at them means
you can kill them. It does. My first thought is how often Trump
uses the idea of his the enemies attacking him. He enjoys when
he can lean into it. Uh
listen try to understand him sometimes he just
it's just personality right? He's just he likes Zoron. He thinks
Zoron's cool. He thinks he he wants to go back to New York City
and not have like problems there as well to some extent, right?
Trump does want to be in New York City. He loves New York City.
So, it's just what he says is right is right. That's the whole
idea of of Trumpism, MAGA, right? It's just a cult of personality.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Rhox, he's just he's going
to flip on this cuz he's like, "Oh, now it's like cool to to
hang out with this guy and to have a good
>> This war. I would have never this war never would have
happened. I inherited this war. And I thought he should have
made a deal
a year ago, two years ago. The ultimate deal would have been
if it never started. That would have been the good deal. That
could have been done, too, if you had the right president. But
you didn't have the right president.
>> Mr. President, Mr. President, Mr. President, cost of
living is something that you and Mr. Montani seem to agree on.
Uh, Democrats have run New York City for a long time, Mr. Montani.
>> Do you see Democrat policy specifically as being a problem
and I'd like that be a question that both of you?
>> Look, I think that there are many things in our city
where we have to own the responsibility of it. Things that existed
long before the president was the president. And those are also
part of the message of our campaign was to take on a broken politics
of the past. And I ran against a number of candidates who represented
different versions of that past. And what we found time and again
is that working people were left behind in the politics of our
city. And what we're looking to do is put those
>> um not to both sides this, but but both sides would
do this substance, right? The second Trump is like trying to
say one of his policies are bad, the second there's like something,
they'll both just flip on each other. But I think probably if
they have some kind of personal relationship that leads to like
an understanding that there's like a backdoor there's a there's
a back channel available that we could talk through things but
we're going to we we both understand there's like some kayfabe
going on in public. I think that's typically the relationship
that view that forms with Trump is they realize they have to
fight in public and Trump's going to go hard on people in public
but it's like sort of it's like to some extent kayfabe and they
can talk behind the scenes and it could be okay. I think that's
normally the way this >> People, right?
>> Although, there are also times where Trump takes the
kayfabe if somebody like hits him back hard enough. So, like
Trump's like the kid who's like, "We can we can play fight, but
I always get to hit harder and if you hit me as hard as I hit
you, uh, now I'm going to throw haymakers. You now I'm going
to throw haymakers." So, Trump's the guy who like wants to play
fight, he's always wanting to do it. And then somebody hits him
a little bit and he starts crying and like trying to beat you
to death.
back at the heart of our politics so that we don't have a situation
where we're in the wealthiest city in the history of the world
and yet one in five can't even afford $2.90 for a metro >> Mr.
President, >> you know, we had some interesting conversation
and some of his ideas really are the same ideas that I have.
Uh but a big thing on cost. You know, the the new word is affordability.
Another word is just groceries. You know, it's sort of an oldfashioned
word, but it's it's very accurate. And affordability talks about
more than just like um I guess like grocery prices. It's an affordability
crisis cuz rents would be rising. Every every bit of cost everywhere
in the world is like rising for everybody and wages are not rising.
In fact, probably mo most people are like getting you know they're
I guess I was going to say getting laid off. It's like structural
unemployment. Like companies can't afford to hire people. Everything's
more expensive. Companies can't afford to hire people. People
have less money, but everything costs more. It's just it's all
right.
So, it's an affordability crisis because
it's not just about the grocery prices. It's everything. Everything's
>> They're coming down. They're coming down. They were,
you know, we had both of us. We had the high >> I think
I think my landlord is trying to get a hold of me right now.
He's trying to get a hold of me when I was gone for a while and
now he's like, "Hey, let me know when you're back. I need to
talk to you." And it's like, I know you're trying to get to talk
to me before December so that you can give me my notice that
my rent's going up. I know what you're doing. Don't just say
you want to talk. Why not just say why you want to talk? Why
not just say it over the phone?
Just move. I'm about to just move in with my parents. Okay. I
not that like I could totally afford to be out and renting, but
it's like I'm I'm so done with like paying extra rent right now.
I've got
We'll see. We'll see. I've got like a second property.
I think there's a chance I could I mean
I have to I have to do one of two things. I either have to buy
a house or I have to go live with my parents. I feel like I don't
want to rent anymore.
I think I I don't want to rent anymore. So I've either got to
buy a house or
I got to go figure something else. Don't you own property? I
do. Not where I live though.
And the the cabin I own is not year round. Like the it's in an
area where the water isn't even on in the winter. So you have
to deal with the the water issue in the winter, which is kind
of annoying. So
yeah. So I basically just have to find somewhere I can live or
buy a house. I don't know. We'll figure out. >> Highest
inflation in the history of our country the last four years under
the Biden administration. And we've got inflation down now to
a normal number. It's going to go even a little bit lower than
that. Katie, do you have something in a minute? Thank you so
much.
>> In what universe do they have inflation down to a normal
number? Everything is still inflating.
Where is this the case? Is there a magic place? Do I have to
move to the states? Is there a magic place in the USA where actually
inflation is down? Actually cost of living is down. Is there
a magical area where this is actually happening?
He says he just says it. It's like dude what the
what the is going on? What are you talking about? Same place.
Gas is $150. Gas is three bucks everywhere. Gas is like 280 at
best per gallon. Okay. I just drove through a bunch of the United
States. Gas is not a$150 anywhere. I drove through like 15 states.
Okay. Gas is not a dollar anywhere.
>> US Constitution. What is your response to that?
Oh, also
gas would be lower. I think basically all the gas stations I
went to were off of like one of the interstates or whatever.
I'm guessing those gas stations are always a little more expensive
than like a small town that's not on one of the major interstates,
I'm guessing all of those little like truck stop areas where
they off
those would all be probably more expensive. Well, I don't know
what you're referring to in terms it can be covered by international
law and local law. It's covered by a lot of laws and uh but uh
it's covered by US law. Are you referring to anything in particular?
>> You just said that they're a state that endorses and
enforces international law
that odds with >> No, I don't know. Would you want to
you want to
>> Oh, hold on.
Corwin Chel thinks that this is a subtle threat by Mandani.
Groceries I read as code for don't forget to kiss the ring. I
mean, that's true that cities do need like uh food coming in
from other places, but New York City's a major port city. Like
they can pull in food from other places if they have to. Um Trump
could with things, but that would be like an insane escalation.
Not saying he wouldn't do that with that, but that would be a
totally insane escalation.
Be crazy.
Um, and realistically, what is he going to do that's worse than
what it already is, than what's already happened? I don't know.
He's already tariffing the [__] out of everything.
Although, I think they've taken down what? Beef tariffs are gone.
Guys,
our way of solving the affordability crisis is we're going to
take the tariffs off of select things. It's like, wait, what?
So, you admit the tariffs increase prices? What? Huh? Oh, hold
on.
Reox just sent me a tweet Trump threw out. I have just gotten
the highest poll numbers of my political career. While the my
great work on the economy has not yet been fully appreciated,
it will be. Things are really rocking. Stopping wars and foreign
relations seem to be a strong suit. Also great, the border and
stopping crime. I predict that the economy with the already highest
stock market ever and prices coming down sharply from the Biden
disaster will soon be at the top of the list. Make America great
again. He just he just says things. He just says, "Guys, everything's
great. Everything's great. Could you imagine this is is he just
learning from Netanyahu? Listen guys, we're we're looking for
peace. We are not civilians. We're not You just like make up
whatever you want.
I Who knew that in an age where you can get like instant facts
on anything that the most powerful tool you can fact check anything
in real time whenever you want, the most powerful tool in the
world will still be just lying. just lying overtly in a way that's
easily disproven,
right? Just lie. Just lie and you win.
Just Just lie and you win every time. I believe this is mostly
funny because I think he's at the lowest polling point of his
entire career. Is he not? Last I checked, he was like extremely
he was pulling extremely badly. Polls, President Trump job approval.
Yeah. Does he did he look at this and he was like, "Yeah, red's
good. Red's good. Red's pretty good. Listen, red's pretty good.
55.6%
disapprove.
Look, it's going up. Look, this red line, it's going up, guys.
It's going up big time. Getting the biggest numbers of our careers.
Still higher than January 7th, 2021. Oh, okay. Wait, where does
this go back to? Oh, this is just this year. This is just this
term,
guys. We just got the best polling of our career over here.
What would this have been? Minus four 47%.
Huh. Maybe this might be Listen, a Rasmmanson poll coming in
last minute. Make it look like he's doing maybe. What is this?
Mike Mike Singleton.
What's this? Analyst Har
the last 10 days of Trump polls. The numbers are just atrocious.
CNN data analyst Harry Anon. I hate Harry Anon. Well, I used
to hate Harry Anton, but I might actually I might have to admit
that I don't hate Harry Anton anymore. Because why I used to
hate him was because Wait, what the [__] going on
with this? 6,000 views, 61 retweets, 325 likes. How?
How? 61 retweets. Harry Anon is he's a former 538 employee, like
a former Nate Silver employee who went on to be the major data
analyst at CNN. And he was just a huge Trump guy. Sorry, huge
Clinton guy. Not a huge Trump guy. hates hates Trump, but he
was a massive Clinton booster. He was one of the guys who was
like, "Clinton's got this. Clinton's got this. Clinton's got
this. Clinton's got this. Oh, wait. My life is over." Uh, he
was the big Clinton booster. He's always He is like the neoliberal
of the 538 crew. Status quo is always good. Status quo is always
good. Here, I'm going to hit play on this. I'll be right back.
>> Data analyst Harry Eton is here on this special Friday.
It's been a tough few days for the president in the polls. >> Yeah,
John Burman. I would say this is probably the worst 10-day period
for the president in the polls his entire second term. The numbers
are just atrocious. What are we talking about here in terms of
net approval rating? Well, take a look. These are all November
polls. The best one of the group puts him at 14 points underwater.
That's the Marquette University Law School poll. Tied for the
worst he's ever had in that poll. Fox 17 points underwater. Maris
17 points underwater. The Reuters Ipsos poll 22 points underwater.
And then taking the cake, the AP North Pole 26 points underwater
when your best poll has you still 14.
>> Dude, I Trump like sees stuff like this and he's just
like, I'm going to listen. I'm just going to say the exact opposite
of that. Whatever that guy's saying, I'm saying the opposite.
I'm going the other >> Points underwater. You know, it's
truly bad. And it's as bad as 26 points underwater. We're talking
about an average well well underwater with the deep blue sea
swimming with the fishes. And now this is all parties here. If
you think >> Why is he doing it? It is like an ESPN thing,
but it's like a New York accent. ESPN thing.
I don't The New York accent is like throwing me off big time
here.
Walking the screen in numbers. It's the energy. It's the energy
of the of it that is making it seem like a sports broadcast.
way way way in under the blue in the under the ocean swimming
with the fishes. He's swimming with the fishes over here. >> This
is bad, Harry. If you think this is bad, what is driving these
horrific numbers for Donald Trump? >> Dude, what is the
body language?
Dude, he's like he's not just justiculating with his hands. He's
like putting his whole body into it. >> Driving these horrific
numbers for D >> these horrific numbers over here. I I'm
breaking into my New York accent. That's not intentional. That's
my bad. >> Trump. Well, why don't we take a look at independence?
Trump's net approval.
>> That in my defense. Okay. In my defense, I believe he
is a person from New York. So, that's probably >> going
with independence. Back in January, he was close to even. He
was at minus four points. Not great, but not
Look at this number. 43
points underwater with independence in the most recent average
of these polls. when you
>> Okay, I I'm only early life checking this to defend
the accent. Okay, was raised in a family in the Riverdale neighborhood
of the Bronx in New York City. Okay, I'm just doing it to defend
the accent cuz I was It's an accurate accent in this case. Okay,
that's all. I just We're not doing anything special. >> Three
points underwater with independence. You know, you're doing terribly.
You can't win with this. If this holds for next year's midterm
election, wave adios, amigos. Goodbye. See you later. To that
House Republican majority and that Senate Republican majority
very much in danger as well. When you take a look at the Pew
Research validated voter survey going back to last year, he was
basically even among independents with Kla.
>> Did the Dems control both the Senate and the House at
any point in the Trump presidency? The first one, 2016, 2018.
Oh, sorry. I know they didn't in 2016. It was a super majority
for the Republicans. But in 2018, did they get I don't think
they got the Senate back, right? I think they just said the House.
Is that correct?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Yeah. I feel like if you flip the Senate
and the House against
Trump, you might actually be able to get some legislation passed
that Republicans would hate. It's his lame It's going to be into
his lame duck period, right? It's going to be You could potentially
get Trump signing crazy. Especially if Trump is thinking about
a third term and they him over.
I don't think they can get the Senate. The map is really rough.
Well, dude, it depends. It seriously depends on how underwater
they go cuz Trump, you know, signing the Epstein file stuff to
to get that all released. Like, if if these stories keep happening,
there might be a point where it doesn't matter anymore, right?
And let's not forget that when Trump is not on the ballot himself,
>> it will just be your pain. >> They never go hard.
They always go hard. >> Donated $3. Hold on. >> Started
speaking Spanish but didn't say see you later in a Mexican accent.
I wonder why. >> I do wonder why.
>> Yeah. So, given like all of the extenduating circumstances
of these midterms, I think even with the map bad, like really
bad, you could see some
We'll see though. They'd have to keep they'd have to keep this
momentum of just like totally everything.
Cost of catering to low propensity voters. Well, in terms of
them cratering, it's not just that. It's also
uh it's just it's not even low propensity. It's like the cult
of personality. Like even the people who follow stuff, they probably
are just like they don't care. They don't care enough, right?
Like there would be Trump voters who follow everything Trump
says, but they don't care about going to vote in the elections
cuz Trump doesn't really care. They have to like push Trump to
actually go and support these people. Like anyone running in
the midterms, he'd have to he'd have to ease up on the tariffs
substance at this point. I feel like everything's man.
I the tariffs are the tariffs have to go, but he thinks that
that's going to end up working out. Anyway, like I said, if you
could somehow get both the Senate and the House, I feel like
with Trump being the only person who can veto stuff, like usually
with a Republican president that would go like, oh, nothing,
no legislation's getting through, only stuff that we need, right?
But with Trump, I feel like you could convince him that some
of the stuff is good.
Like like I think you can get some crazy policy passed. I I don't
know. We'll see. Donald Trump, have you ever seen this thing
we call Obamacare? Wait, no. Trump Care, our new medical bill.
It's It's kind of like Obamacare, but it'll be called Trump Care
now. All right. It'll be awesome. It'll be based. >> Now
he is 43 points underwater. Whatever he is doing with independence,
it ain't working. They despise him at this point. >> That
is just a colossal. >> Oh my god. It's a 40 point move.
Okay, that's among certain political groups here. How about what
issues may be driving this? >> Okay, yes, so we say that
independents are driving Trump's decline overall, but what is
pushing independence and the rest of the electorate away from
Donald Trump, away from Donald Trump? John Burman, move out of
the screen, away from Donald Trump. Well, it has everything to
do with inflation. It's the cost of living, baby. That is the
name of the game. You go back to January, he was three points
above water. This was the reason why that voters gave him a second
term. You look at this. Look at this now. 34 points.
>> Dude, it's crazy to campaign on lowering prices and
then be like, I'm going to do the one thing we guarantee increases
prices. I'm going to just tax everything. I'm going to tax everything
massively.
Global taxes on every single supplier in the world. Guys, the
prices will come down.
>> Underwater. My goodness gracious. That is a 37point
move in the wrong wrong
>> All right. Oh my goodness. M but I'll give you a $2,000
check. Maybe that man.
It's It's wild stuff.
Okay. Well, interesting. So, that's why Trump is apparently saying
that he is pulling incredibly. He is not.
>> Let's let's think what what I've shared with the president
is our desire to not only follow the laws of our own city, laws
that protect New Yorkers, but also a desire for consistency in
our politics across the board. And that's something that we've
talked about and [clears throat] something that I know many New
Yorkers want.
>> we we discussed ICE and New York City and I spoke about
how the laws that we have in New York City allow for New York
City government to speak to the federal administration for about
170 serious crimes. The concerns that many New Yorkers have are
around the enforcement of immigration laws on New Yorkers across
the five burrows. And most recently, we're talking about a mother
and her two children. how this has very little to do with what
that is. >> What we did is we discussed crime >> more
than ICE per se. We discussed crime and he doesn't want to see
crime and I don't want to see crime and I have very little doubt
that we're not going to get along on that issue. He wants to
and he said some things that were very interesting, very interesting
as to housing construction and he wants to see houses go up.
He wants to see a [laughter] lot of houses created, a lot of
apartments built, etc. And you know, I we we actually uh people
>> Oh, that's a that's a smart one to cater to Trump's
ego. It's like, listen, [music] we need huge apartments. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Leaning into the real estate thing. Exactly. Turnup.
Yes,
dude. That's a great way to cater to Trump's ego. Listen, we
need we might need you to consult with us cuz we want to build
tons of apartments in New York City. We want this to be we want
this city to be huge and we're going to need the infrastructure.
We're going to need like subway improvements to support it. We're
going to need everything going in one direction and you can help
us with the real estate stuff. Okay. Yeah. Obviously, increasing
the supply of housing in New York is required, Corwin. But I'm
telling you, he's going to lean into Trump's ego on that. He's
going to say, "We might need you to consult with us on what developers
to go to on how to get this stuff done cuz you're the guy who
knows everything." This might be the one place where you could
say Trump is an expert building buildings in New York. Okay?
Building large large building projects in New York. This might
be the one place where you could actually without without just
you know crossing your fingers behind your back coe I think you
could help us on this. I think you might know something about
>> You'd be shocked but I want to see the same thing.
>> Jack, Mr. I I want to know one of the uh policies as
well that uh Mayor Le Montami talked a number of times about
on the campaign was shifting the tax burden for property taxes
from what he called minority communities to whitebased communities
and putting more taxes on
>> this is this is like a really
oh man I think this was a landmine that Mani's campaign didn't
need to step on cuz I I just got the context on this. I think
Dung Devil gave me the context on this earlier today. All right.
Okay. Hold on. Hold on. Where is it? Here. It's right here. Okay.
So, this is the context on this. Okay. So, this is the context.
Now, on the site, it's really stupid how they had it written
out. Okay. Manny basically
he basically says, "No, no, no. That's not that's not what we
actually think." Okay. But
oh man, on the on the site, the policy was actually bad. But
he does a good job of explaining it here. There's no benefit.
>> We went on your website and realized there's a policy
proposal that says your plan, and I'm going to quote it for folks,
is to shift the tax burden from overtaxed homeowners in the outer
burrows to more expensive homes in richer and whiter neighborhoods.
Explain why you are bringing race into your tax >> That
is just an description of what we see right now. It's not driven
by race. It's more of an assessment of what neighborhoods are
being undertaxed versus overt taxed. We >> So he says it's
just descriptive. It's not like the prescription isn't to tax
white people. It's to to move the tax burden to other neighborhoods.
Now I think we'll see I guess possibly right here if that's really
what he meant that it's just descriptive. Right. I I just generally
I need a lot of evidence to say that people are like openly overtly
racist. like to to say we're prescribing white people pay more
taxes. I don't
that would obviously tank any campaign. I just believe somebody
wrote that in a way that
uh it's like leaning into the the progressive way of describing
it, but but also
it's not important. He he won't stand on >> We've seen
time and again that this is a property tax system that is inequitable.
It's one that actually Eric Adams ran on saying that he would
change.
[laughter] >> Yeah. Yeah. Reversing the roles here, Luawi,
is probably something you could do. And it looks pretty bad.
[laughter] Listen, we need to get out of these We need to get
the police to really crack down on these high crime, blacker
neighborhoods, okay? We need the police to crack down in these
high crime, blacker neighborhoods. That's just the way it is.
All right? And people are like, "Whoa, are you going to you're
going to increase enforcement on black people?" No, it's just
descriptive. That's where the crime happens. That's that's just
where the crime happens, guys. It's just descriptive. Okay?
in the first 100 days. He's since sought to defend it and lost
at every juncture in court. >> And I understand you're
saying we're simply describing the types of neighborhoods that
would see these increase in taxes. And yet by invoking race,
do you run the risk of potentially alienating key constituents?
>> I think I'm just naming things as they are. And ultimately
my the the thing that motivates
>> I ah
it is actually [__] annoying. Okay. If you're going
to name things as they are, I want a lot more race-based comedy
coming out of you, Mr. Mr. Mum Donnie.
Can we talk about the
Can we talk about people who are over represented perhaps on
Wall Street and in politics in general? Can we start talking
about that and just say we're describing reality? Can we talk
about crime and and what races might be over represented in crime
and talk about reality?
It is it is annoying that he leans into this. It's like super
progressive. It's there's no reason to, right? There's just no
there's no reason me in this is to create a system of fairness.
It is not to work backwards from an erracial assessment of neighborhoods
or our city. Rather, it's to ensure that we actually have an
equal playing field. And right now, what we see with the property
tax system is one that is overt taxing a number of New Yorkers
and undertaxing others and an inability of political will to
resolve >> So, no plans to change that language on your
website. That's >> the the focus here is to actually ensure
a fair property tax system. that the use of that language is
just an assessment of the neighborhood. >> All right. You
are a self-described democratic socialist. Do you think that
>> it's worse when you're talking about crime as it's definitionally
negative? The whiter neighborhoods referring to more wealthy
people. Not a negative. It's still kind of stupid. Just shouldn't
have been mentioned.
Okay. So, hold on. Contend with the one then.
Who's over represented? Who's over represented in in Wall Street
in? Contend with that one. That's not negative. It's just saying
that they're like, you know, they kind of control money. They
kind of control media.
[laughter] We don't apply that. Nobody applies that lens equally,
right? Uh this is a man I don't want to go off at all. I really
don't want to be this guy. I never want to cover this stuff and
like give these opinions, but like that's why when I say white
people might be a little weirded out, a little worried that they're
like not being treated equally. It's because of like that, right?
That's exactly why.
That's how you get the little Timmy hypothetical. That's just
how it >> That billionaires have a right to exist.
>> I don't think that we should have billionaires because
frankly it is so much money in a moment of such >> he should
he should really lean into that. Yeah, I think we should guillotine
all billionaires. He should just lean into it. Okay. All right.
This is So there's a little bit of defense. There's a little
bit of wiggle room. We'll see how they analyze the situation.
white people. I also noticed that in your acceptance group you
didn't mention didn't mention anything about America or Christians
or white people in general. And so I didn't know if that was
one of the policies that you guys had spoken >> We focused
on affordability. We focused on the cost of living crisis. What
I will say is that I am very much interested in property tax
reform because what we see right now in New York City is a system
that is so inequitable that it can't even stand up in court.
And the president and I spoke about the importance of not only
building more housing, but also making sure that regulation of
housing is something that is manageable to actually get through
and not the cause of yet another weight that we see in our >> To
be clear, you're continuing this idea of race-based properties.
>> No, to be very clear. >> No, the the the the use
of the term was a description of neighborhoods, not a description
of intent. >> So, you intend to tax the whiter neighborhoods
more? >> No, we Sorry, somebody said Jack. Is it literally
Jack Bobic? It is. Okay.
So you intent So you intend to tax the white neighborhoods more?
No, we just because the whiter neighborhoods are richer, we will
end up taxing them more. So your intent is to tax white people.
Nope. Nope. It's literally not. That's not the intent. That's
not the intent here. So it's the intent. No, it's not the intent.
So it's the intent. No, it's not the intent. So it's the intent
to tax white people. It's no.
No. No. No. No. Hold on. Free exec. It's like if you said we
need stop and frisk back because there's these high crime neighborhoods
who are like we need way more way more cops there. We need to
be way more way more harsh in these high crime neighborhoods.
Right? The effect of that would be overpolicing black people
automatic in New York City. Okay. It would absolutely just be
overpolicing black people.
And this is the same thing. So if if they were saying, you know,
there's these black neighborhoods where there's a ton of crime,
that could be descriptively true, but it wouldn't be that you
need to crack down on it because they're black because they're
high crimes.
Careful, Mr. The only reason you got those shekels from BB will
make me tighten the leash.
>> Okay. Thank you very much, Mr. Liboitz.
Fantastic stuff. With that lovely donation from Mr. Liowitz,
we have another hour on the stream. I'm going to go ahead and
add that now. Thank you very much, Moshe Liowitz. Appreciate
it,
Don't tighten the leash. More more shekels. More shekel. >> We
intend to create a fair property tax system because we want a
New York City that is not only fair and equitable, but also one
that >> um free exec, I'm criticizing the description that
you shouldn't say we're we're going to target neighborhoods that
are richer and then include that that corresponds to whiter.
You shouldn't be doing that, right? But he is making it very
clear what he means and that it's a description and that they
I would like to see him say that realistically I don't believe
we should put that in there. We shouldn't be looking at things
based on race. That would be super easy for him to do. I don't
know. I haven't quite heard that yet.
I don't know if he thinks that that's a like a loss for him.
He could say, "While while I do believe that it is a descriptor
and that it's not harmful, I do understand that some people get
concerned about it and so we probably shouldn't have used it."
It's like super easy.
>> Whatever you can afford.
>> My my concern here is with the comfort in using the
whiter descriptor, right? When you wouldn't do that with other
racial groups ever. If he did that with groups, they would be
even more upset than they already are with him. It's it's just
a stupid thing to do. Um, and for some reason, the only race
that people stand on business with this,
the only reason they ever stand on business with regards to this
exact topic is because it's white people who are complaining.
It's like white people that they're using to describe something.
Something is white. Whiteness is bad, right? That like essentialism
is still sort of clapped at by progressives.
I think it's goofy.
Uh, I don't find fault with it just because it's accurate. the
wealthy community is mostly white.
Okay, then I I just want that we can apply that lens evenly if
you guys like, but I'm telling you that there are other groups
where that exact same concept is used and then they get mad about
racial uh like I guess bigotry against them, right? Talk about
how people are over represented in certain places and then everybody
goes like obviously there's an intent to why you're saying it.
I don't know what Zoron's intent here is, right? to why why they
wrote it down that way. It could be that it's effective electioneering,
like, hey, we'll get more votes than we'll lose. That could be
it. It could be that, you know, he really hates white people.
That could be it. It could be that some intern did it and he
just doesn't want to back off of it because it looks weak weak
to back off of it. Could be that, right? But I don't think that
just because something's a valid description does not mean that
there's nothing bad about using it.
I think this is an example of it wasn't necessary. It wasn't
required. Everything you have to determine the policy is there
when you say richer neighborhoods,
right? That is the only thing they're they're actually filtering
for the with the policy. We're just going for richer neighborhoods.
You don't need the white part. So why did you include the white
part?
If you absolutely don't need it,
why is it there?
And if you can't answer that effectively, if you just say, "Well,
it's it's just true. It happens to be true." If you can't answer
effectively why it's there,
then I'm very suspicious of why you put it there.
He's saying, "Oh, it's just a descriptive descriptive reality."
That is unfortunately, although it is a negative attribute, not
a positive one. It's the same thing people do. It's the same
thing Nick Fentes does when he points out that people are over
represented in Congress by a factor of like 30,
right? And then he goes, "I'm just describing reality." Well,
you're describing reality that way for a reason, obviously.
Please go ahead. [clears throat] >> Mr. M, you can say
Israel protesters just targeted a synagogue in New York. >> The
current day populism on the left has created an enemy that is
intersected by inordinate amount of wealth they own and their
white race.
Um, kind of. Yeah, sure. I think there's there's a lot of things
that there is like an anti-whitness, anti-white bias on the left
in terms of leftist populism. I don't think it's like inherent.
Certainly wasn't inherent in anything Bernie was doing, right?
And that's always my number one bellweather is like, would Bernie
support that? Would he talk about that? Bernie is truly like
just a class-based socialist, right? He doesn't believe in race.
He doesn't care about race. I've he will he will talk about people
who are persecuted based on the race, but he won't go, "Oh, well,
these people are, you know, making way too much and we have to
take from them." Unfortunately, this is the same logic that Scotas
used to rule on the N uh North Carolina gerrymandering maps.
These maps are drawn on partisan lines. The races of those affected
while highly correlative are coincidental. Yes.
Yes. But I mean it can be it can be true as well. One took over.
Like you could be you could be gerrymandering based on not race.
I I think that's fair. I unfortunately think that's fair
because here's the thing.
Do you think the Republicans Here's just what do you think the
overriding principle is there? Do you think Republicans would
just not gerrymander because they had to include black people
in their district? Like if those black people would vote for
them, they would include them, right? Like they're they're just
gerrymandering. Like people are actually North Carolina. Hold
on. Is this this is them gerrymandering, isn't it, in North Carolina
or is this a while back? In any case, I can't remember when this
was. If it was a while back, it was probably Republican. If it's
recent, then it's probably Democrat. But um I'm just saying I
think the overriding principle there is just do you vote Republican?
I I would love if the Supreme Court could stand up business and
say that like somehow find a way to argue that jerrymandering
is just wrong. That would be cool.
Um not anymore. I thought Prop 50 passed. Didn't the Prop 50
pass? I thought California is doing it. Yeah. No, I think Dems
are planning to do it everywhere now. One took over and I
is it what is the state? It's Is it Virginia? Oh, I'm trying
to think. It's where Jay Jones was. Is that Is that
J. Jones.
J. Jones. Wherever that was where they won governor and they
won it is Virginia. Yes. So where they won governor in AG. I
think they're going to plan to do in Virginia some gerrymandering
as well. Like it seems likely that Virginia is going to be a
the idea of gerrymandering there might be up for grabs.
>> Virginia can try but it's very purple. I don't know
if that would work.
Uh, you could you could overload, right? I've There's We should
watch something on the Jerry mandering math again. I wouldn't
mind watching something on gerrymandering math cuz I I always
find it interesting to figure out where like basically once you
gerrymander enough, you at the risk of like a a change election,
like a wave election, you can lose like all of your seats.
I'll I'll maybe watch something on it after this. >> Jewish
welcome state in the city. And President Trump, you threatened
to call federal funding to New York City. What policies would
cost you to do that? Would that be city run grocery stores? Would
it be something else? >> Well, I think if we didn't get
along, whether it's cut off or just
[laughter]
the question was, hey, some people don't feel safe in New York.
What? What? And Trump, you said you'd cut off funding to New
York City given certain policies. What are the policies that
you cut it off for? And the first thing he goes is, well, if
we didn't get along, if he was like rude to me, I'd cut him off.
That's so insane. Like it's it's just based on his ego entirely.
Well, I think if he was like mean to me, I think if he was like
an to me, then yeah, I'd have to cut him off. I'd have to cut
off all federal funding for everybody else there. >> Make
it a little bit difficult or not give as much. We want to see
I use the term we don't want good money going after bad. And
uh we just uh we don't want that to happen. I don't think that's
going to happen. I did say, you know, subject to what what policies
are being said. We had a meeting today that actually surprised
me. He wants to see no crime. He wants to see housing being built.
He wants to see rents coming down. All things that I agree with.
Now, we may disagree how we get there, the rent coming down.
I think uh one of one of the things I really gleaned very very
much today. He'd like to see him come down ideally by building
a lot of additional housing. That's the ultimate way. He agrees
with that and so do I. If I read the newspapers and the stories,
I don't hear I don't hear that. But I hear I heard him say it
today and I think that's a very positive step. No, >> that's
funny cuz one I think basically everybody I can't think of a
more bipartisan thing than everywhere needs more housing now,
right? Is there anything more bipartisan than that? Like Americans
look at China building, you know, like double the units that
they need for their entire population and Americans are like,
"Oh god, how do we get that? How the do we get that shit?"
So I I fully believe Bomb Donnie has been talking about housing
starts. We need to build house uh housing, high density housing
all over New York City, right? But Trump's just never seen it.
He's in a bubble. He's in a media bubble. No, >> I don't
expect I I expect to be helping
Um, abundance is basically just Well, hold on. No, no, no, no,
no. You don't get to take the the one policy everybody agrees
on and make that a part of the abundance agenda, is he? I'm sorry.
Abundance is about some stuff like that, like getting rid of
that. But everybody agrees that there's too much red tape around
building houses. That's not That's not just an abundance agenda
thing. Oh, we need to cut the red tape on this. That's Everybody
thinks that. Wait, so housing is good? No. No. Uh, China has
way overb built on housing to the point that they might have
like done significant damage to their economy and their their
like future prospects for an economy by building it. They took
a ton of lending. They they borrowed a bunch of money and they
built tons and tons of housing because that was the way you could
do investment in China. It's what everybody was used to. They
just buy second apartments and all this. And now they have like
more apartments than they have people by like a huge factor.
So it's like empty. I'm saying people are like in America they're
like, "Oh, I wish we had that instead of this." or in Canada
or Australia where the the prices are just insane. Like absolutely
insane.
>> Not hurting him. A big help because I want New York
City to be great. Look, I love New York City. It's where I come
from. I spent a lot of years there. Now I'm right here. Uh we
took a big setback with a mayor that we had, Dame Delasio.
I thought it was a tremendous setback for the city. I think this
mayor could do some things that are going to be really great.
Okay, how about you? You >> go ahead, please.
>> Why did he take a shot at Delasio there? Hold on. >> Because
I want New York City to be great. Look, I love New York City.
It's where I come from. I spent a lot of years there. Now I'm
right here. Uh we took a big setback with a mayor that we had,
Dame Delasio.
I thought it was a tremendous setback for the city. I think this
mayor can do some things that are going to be really >> Mr.
President,
Mr. president. >> Okay. How about you? You go ahead, >> You're
a billionaire. You've got a different address nowadays than you
used to, but you used to call New York City home. Would you feel
comfortable living in New York City under a Mandi >> Yeah,
I would. I really would. Especially after the meeting.
>> What makes you comfortable?
>> We agree on a lot more than I would have thought.
Um I think he's uh I want him to do a great job and we'll help
him do a great job. You know, he may have different views,
but in many ways, you
>> bro, side profile on Trump's got to go insane, right?
Like, I think he wants to frame his face so that it doesn't look
like he's got like a big double chin going on. And he's leaning
so far forward out of his chair. Like, the the perspective is
going nuts in the camera here. Like his head is like twice the
size of Mani's,
right? Yeah. The side profile here, like he's actually he's actually
leaning so far forward. It's crazy. >> We were discussing
when Bernie Sanders was out of the race. I picked up a lot of
his votes and >> Yeah, he does have that gamer neck. Yeah,
he's got like the super kyphotic.
>> I have no idea because he was strong on not getting
ripped off in trade and lots of the things that I've practiced
and and been very successful on. Uh tariffs, a lot of things.
Bernie Sanders and I agreed on much more than people thought.
And when he was uh put out of the race, I think quite unfairly
if you want to know the truth, uh many of the Bernie Sanders
voters voted for me and I felt very comfortable, frankly, in
seeing that and saying that. And you know, it just turned out
to be a a statistical truth. But um no, I feel very comfortable
I would be I would feel very very comfortable being in New York
and I think much more so after the meeting. Yes, please. Thanks.
I have a question for you, but a very quick one for the mayor.
Why did you fly here? Aren't trains greener?
>> I'll use every form of transit, and I want to make sure
that they're all affordable in New York City. And that's why
making buses fast and free is a centerpiece of our bus. >> Well,
but no, but to be fluid, that's a lot quicker, too. [laughter]
>> No, I mean, he's he's working very hard for him to be
it's a long that's a very that's a very long drive. I'll stick
up for you. You know, the plane takes you 30 minutes and driving
takes you long. I was wondering if you could clear up uh some
confusion around a Washington Post report. Uh there's this explo
>> Hold on one second. Root of the problem is overregulation,
pointless regulations that only exist. Yeah, this is now there's
a part of the abundance agenda, but I think a lot of people do
know this Marty like a lot of people have identified this. it's
that the people who can go to the extremely like
you know, council meetings and stuff to actually argue about
this, they don't want a lot of the new stuff, right?
But hold on, I didn't even read your whole thing. Um, this about
the regulations that exist only to benefit different unions.
That's why Oh, this is different. Hold on. This is different.
This is different. I was doing nimiism in general, but that's
why every building in NYC is perpetually scaffolded. Unions lobby
the hell out of establishment dems in cities like NYC. They have
ultimate say on whether or not a development will actually be
built or sabotaged. If a developer does not hire a union, the
union will file endless sham lawsuits against every developer
claiming their project violates some obscure environmental regulation.
I see.
H I've heard that the unions have like a lot of power in New
York. The the unions were like almost weren't the unions like
almost equivalent to the mob in New York at one point? Am I crazy?
I don't know a lot of American history, but I feel like they
were basically like organized crime there for a while. report
that the Coast Guard is no longer going to characterize SWAT
defensive abuses as hate symbols. >> Oh, they still are.
They are the mob. They still are. Okay. All right.
>> DHS called that a lie and fake news. Can you clear up?
>> I don't know anything about it. When When was this written?
>> I think yesterday. >> Well, look, the Coast Guard's
an incredible group of people. I know them very well. We just
ordered a lot of new Coast Guard cutters. Beautiful. The most
magnificent ship. They look like yachts with lots of guns on
them. Uh so I I don't know. I haven't seen any report like that.
But certainly we want them to remain a great force and they are.
>> And you did a piece in all the nine months around the
world. I would like to ask Mr. Mandani, you've accused the US
government of committing genocide in Gaza while President Trump
was working on peace. Why? Why that? >> I I've spoken about
the Israeli government committing genocide and I've spoken about
our government funding it. And I shared with the president in
our >> Oh. Oh, Ian Carol streams on Twitch.
Cancel Ian Carol.
>> The East Coast. That's a 2hour time difference. Carol
streaming on Twitch. >> No speed of Isn't so fast that
it's going backwards 2 hours. >> That's crazy. >> But
I just saw that >> because it's the the time difference
is >> secret Egyptian military planes live research. Charlie
Kirk investigation >> reported to the East Coast. It still
wouldn't. Dude, this guy's living the life. All right, this guy
is a prolific conspiracy theorist. He just does conspiracy theories
live on Twitch. That's awesome.
That's so cool. Twitch never beating the anti-semitism allegations
with Ian Carol up there. His His account is literally called
cancel Ian Carol. >> That's very funny to me. >> Jump
in time back. >> Sorry. I do find I do find that very funny.
It's very cool,
very based. Let's get back to this >> about the concern
that many New Yorkers have of wanting their tax dollars to go
towards the benefit of New Yorkers and their ability to afford
basic dignity. And what we see right now is we're in the ninth
consecutive year of more than 100,000 school children being homeless
in our city. And there's a desperate need not only for the following
of human rights, but also the following through on the promises
we've made New Yorkers. And I appreciated the meeting we had
and the work that we can do. Do you agree that President Trump
[clears throat] did do a peace and work hard to make the peace
because he worked hard to do the peace in the Middle East and
everywhere? What do you agree with that? I appreciate all efforts
towards peace and I shared with President Trump that when I spoke
to Trump voters on Hillside Avenue, including one of whom was
a pharmacist that spoke about how President Trump's father actually
went to that pharmacy not too far from Jamaica states, that people
were tired of seeing our tax dollars fund endless wars. And I
also believe that we have to follow through on the international
human rights. And I know that still today those are being violated
and that continues to be work that has to be done no matter where
we're speaking of. >> Mr. President,
thank you Mr. President. Do you view the mayor elect as the true
leader of the Democrat party and do you think you need to know
how to follow his lead? >> Well, look, I hope they have
great leaders. This is a man that right now I think is focused
on New York City.
I really think has a chance to do a great job. We're going to
help him, but I really think he has a chance to do a great job.
But I'll let you answer that. Do you consider yourself the leader
of the Democrats? I think it's more appropriate for him. >> I
consider myself the the next mayor of New York City and I keep
my horizons firmly on New York City and I appreciate the the
meeting with the president which focused again on the five burrows
and and whether New Yorkers could afford to live there. >> By
the way, being the mayor of New York City is a big deal.
>> I always said, you know, one of the things I would have
loved to be someday is the mayor of New York City. being the
mayor of New York and especially now because I think you're at
really a turning point one way or the other.
>> That's interesting. Trump wants to like him so he's
not willing even though Zoron is a Democrat. He ran as a Democrat.
He was the Democrat candidate. He he must have like some exceptions
in his in his mind like oh well only Democrats can win in New
York City. So like I obviously like Zoron or I like Democrats
in New York City, right? It's very it's very funny. and he just
doesn't want to tie him to the national party. Oh, he's just
focused on New York City. Okay,
that is he could easily do the opposite of that and he doesn't
want to. This is very interesting. >> It can go great or
it can go in a different direction and I think you really have
a chance to make it great.
Mr. President, you said you love New York City, Mr. Matti. Does
New York City love President Trump? >> New York City loves
a future that is affordable. And I can tell you that there were
more New Yorkers who voted for President Trump in the most recent
presidential election because of that focus on cost of living.
And I'm looking forward to working together to deliver on that
affordability agenda. >> Got a lot I got a lot of votes.
>> One more. Go ahead. >> That's uh Sorry. That is
what he takes out of that. I got a lot of votes. I just got a
I've got a lot. >> Two more. Go ahead.
>> I tell you the press has eaten this thing up. You know,
I've had a lot of meetings with the heads of major countries.
Nobody cared. this meeting that you people have gone, you know,
outside you have hundreds of people waiting. This is just a small
little group. For some reason, the press has found this to be
>> Yeah. No, I see it. I see it this way entirely, Matt.
And Zoron leaned into that. This very intelligent from Zoron,
right? Like I could just I can tell you I can see into I can
ponder the orb. I can see exactly how that meeting went. It was
Mr. Trump, the number one thing we need to do to get cost of
living down in New York City is build build. Nobody knows how
to do that better than you. We would love any guidance you have
on how to get through regulations. We're going to slash regulations.
We We want to work with you. We want to work with your team.
We We want to build. We need to make sure New York City is open
for business. So, we want your guidance on this and we think
you are a huge part of New York City's like bright and prosperous
future. I guarantee you that's how he went. That's the line he
went down. And that's just true. Like, you do need to cut regulation.
You do need to start building. And who's built more buildings
in in New York City than Trump? I don't know. There probably
are some people, but I don't hear about him cuz Trump always
talks about the buildings he built in New York City. Okay, so
I know I know that's Trump's guidance. I know. I know. Uh, is
it me or is Trump like energized more than he has been in months?
Trump is enjoying this interview. And yes, this is I I feel that
entirely, Dagda. Yes, that this is Trump. Trump has been like
funny. He's been a little bit witty here. Yeah, maybe it's the
attention. I don't know what it is, but he just seems to be happy.
I guess maybe they have a different news cycle that that's picking
Yeah, I I think that's got to be what it is. Is he's got he's
found a new news cycle. Okay. Nobody's going to be talking about
the Epstein files.
Nobody's talking about me being a I love it. Let me get the jazz
hands back out. >> Be a very interesting meeting. The biggest
people in the world, they come over from countries nobody cares.
But they did care about this meeting and it was a great meeting.
Go ahead. >> Yeah. I was going to ask exactly that. Why
do you think there's so much more, you know, so much excitement
around this thing going forward? >> Because I think he's
different.
All right. I think he's different and that could be in a very
positive way, but I think he's different than, you know, your
typical guy runs, wins, becomes mayor maybe, and nothing exciting
because he has a chance to really do something great for New
York. New York is at a very critical point
and he does need the help of the federal government to really
succeed and we're going to be helping him. But uh he's different
than you know your average candidate. He came out of nowhere.
I said he has a great campaign manager standing over there. He
came out of
he got that Hassan [__] endorsement. Okay. He got
that Hassan [__] endorsement and his campaign took
off.
I don't think that's true. I just like saying it cuz I know it
upsets a lot of >> Came out of nowhere. Would you start
off at one or two? And then I I watched I said, "Who is this
guy?" He was at one, then he was at three, then he was at five,
then he was at nine,
then he went up to 17. I >> ah Trump sees Trump sees himself
in Manny. Mandani is just like me. He came out of nowhere. He's
just like me. >> Let's get a little bit interesting, right?
And then all of a sudden he wins a primary that nobody expected
he was going to win. It's a great
a great tribute. I mean, it's an amazing thing that he did.
>> Is it tapping into something that we've known about
Trump for a long time? Who does Trump like? Trump likes anybody.
Trump likes winners.
Find me a winner that Trump doesn't like. Okay? If you're a winner
and you're willing to be even remotely kind to him, he loves
you. It doesn't matter what your politics are, you could be an
overt communist. All right? If you win and you're nice to him,
this is why he likes every single strongman leader on the planet,
right? It's why he likes all of them because they're just nice
to him because they know that they can if they're nice to him,
he you'll love them, right? Oh, that guy that guy has like a
dictatorship that's built entirely around him and he likes me.
That guy's awesome. Love that dude. >> And I'll just I'll
I'll just add Oh, sorry. I'll just add one thing to to what the
president said is one thing I also appreciated is in in our meeting
to to appreciate a portrait of of FDR and the incredible work
that was done with the New Deal and also in thinking about what
it can look like when the federal government and New York City
government work together to deliver on affordability. It can
be transformative. >> You know, we have a great portrait
of FDR that I found.
>> Oh, I thought Trump would try to walk back from that.
That is okay. that one. I'll give you that one. That that's Mum
Donnie sort of manipulating and making himself look like better.
Like, oh yeah, we he loved FDR. He loved the New Deal. It was
big for America or big for New York. And Trump didn't immediately
push back from that. So, I do think that's like actually a big,
you know, that's in terms of controlling the conversation, getting
the other person to say what you want them to say. That's a that's
a little slight of hand from Mani there >> in the vaults
that was missing for years. I found it and I put it up. He's
a Democrat to the best of my knowledge. He's a Democrat.
And when the mayor saw that portrait, he said, "Sir, do you mind
if I have a picture taken by that port?" It's an amazing portrait.
I hope the picture comes out kind of, >> but it's an amazing
portrait in the cabinet room. >> So, he's a big fan of
the New Deal, I guess, and of FDR. Yes, ma'am. >> Mr. President,
you said that you both spoke about crime. There are many police
officers that come off to roles at the end of this year in New
York City. Uh, are you going to >> Trump Trump was psyched
about this? Okay. Trump now doing a truth truth social photo
dump of his meeting with Zoran Mani, including their pics with
the FDR painting that M Donnie liked.
Picture picture. Dude, why is Zoron Zoron's not doing his smile?
Zoron's totally Trump doesn't even know it. But but Zoron's totally
him here in that he's not doing his normal smile. He's not doing
the goober smile, the like the the toothy grin. He's not even
trying. What the man?
What is he doing?
He's doing this like kind of barely smiling moment. Hold on.
I I swear to God if the picture of Zoron by himself with the
FDR portrait is him like doing the toothy grin. Trump's This
is him by himself. Oh no, he just did this. Dude, what the Did
they just Photoshop Zoron into every single one of these photos?
He's the exact same pose, exact same smile. Did he like workshop
how he could smile in photos with Trump without looking happy?
It's the same in every single one. It's the It's the exact same
smile in all of them. It's like photoshopped.
He's like leaning the same way in every single one of them. Right
shoulder below left
Right shoulder below left shoulder.
Hold on. Hold on. Right shoulder below left shoulder. Why is
this GUY TILTED IN EVERY PICTURE?
What is happening? I don't even believe I believe they got one
picture of Zoron sort of not frowning and they just actually
put it in every
Oh, this one. This one you could tell is like almost the right
shoulder still below the left shoulder. He's holding his hands
the same way in every single one of them. He literally must have
worked on standing this exact way so he could look appropriately
not upset the entire time
or sorry like not upset, not tilted, not happy, just like the
appropriate level of like tepid the whole time.
You know what I'm saying? It's very It's very funny that it to
me this looks like absolutely just coached.
It's very interesting.
It's like not It's not bad. It's just funny to me that he has
the exact same face on. But you look at Zoron smiling in any
of his other photos. This is how he smiles everywhere else, right?
This is literally what he does in every other photo. He does
this same smile. He has like this pisco smile in every photo.
That's not a pisco smile. That's different. The other one was
though. Every photo. This is Zoro Mamani.
This is why I knew that he was gonna This is I was like, "Oh,
this smile. I get it. I get why people voted for him." Okay.
He's like, he just looks like a happy guy. If this guy can figure
out how to be happy, he's an Arab guy living in New York City.
If he can figure out how to be happy, maybe anyone can figure
out how to be happy. I feel like Yeah, I feel like he's workshopped
his smile very significantly
and he knows that this works, but also he's not going to do the
the smile. He's not going to do the winning smile for Trump.
Interesting. It's very interesting. What's the What's the Mum
Donnie tweet? Let's see. Yeah, it's just every every time he
does the same smile. It's the same smile. Oh boy.
That's up. Trump doesn't even know that he's getting insulted.
That Zoron won't even smile standing next to him. >> To
allow those police to be replaced with police officers, actual
cops. And are you going to require that that happens? Would there
be some
>> Hold on. 33 million views for the goober smile. Yeah,
I'm telling you, it's like not he's not like a Hollywood type
like hot dude, but he's like photogenic in a way that he is like
a everyman. He's like the Fred Flintstone of New York City, okay?
He's the everyman and he's the mayor now and he's going to fix
everything. I'm telling you, this smile like won him so many
votes. You guys don't even know.
You don't even know. 33 million views
>> Well, I hope it happens. But again, that's going to
be ultimately the mayor's decision
>> is that I look forward to delivering public safety with
the NYPD. And I've said over the course of our campaign that
we have the number of police officers today, they are the ones
that's budgeted about 35,000 headcount. And I think the key thing
is that we have to make it easier for police to focus on police
work, not ask them to respond to 200,000 mental health calls
a year. >> Oh, somebody posted the Loomer Imager earlier.
Kger, can you just DM that to me? uh imager links get like by
a kick for some reason. Just DM it to me. >> Reduction
from what you're at right now. Are you committing to maintaining
the same levels?
>> I've committed over the course of the campaign to maintain
the 35,000. That's the headcount that we had through the >> Not
replace them with case workers, social workers. >> No,
I've said that's the headcount that we want. What we need to
do is make sure they can focus on serious crime. >> And
he just retained a great police commissioner, I believe. Right.
>> Yes. Yes, we did. Commissioner, if the newspapers are
correct, >> that one they're correct about. >> He
uh he retained I think somebody that is a she's a good friend
of some of the people in my family of Ivanka and they say she's
really good, really competent and he just retained her. So that's
a good sign.
>> And do you think
>> that's that could be I'll just be real. That could be
another sign
of that could be another sign of something he did for Trump.
Trump loves personal favors. Trump loves the idea that he's powerful
enough to pick up the phone and make like the world move overnight,
right? So if you're willing to go, "Oh, you wait. Ivanka likes
that police commissioner. Yeah, we'll keep him." Yeah. Just you
tell them you made a phone call, you made sure. Tell Ivanka,
she can let that guy know she made a phone call and because of
you, they're going to get kept. Okay, they're going to get kept
on. That's that's another thing could do. And maybe mom Donnie
just doesn't really care. Maybe he thought they were doing a
good job or an okay job, right? Maybe he doesn't think there
needs to be turnover, but that's like a thing that he could do
for Trump that would make Trump like a lot more favorable to
him.
>> There will be topics that we disagree on. I think we'll
probably come to a conclusion and
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. I did not catch this. I was paying.
So that's a good >> too much attention to other stuff.
One >> The ones consequence. >> Well, I hope it happens,
but again, that's going to be ultimately the mayor's decision
>> is that I look forward to delivering public safety with
the NYPD. And I've said over the course of our campaign that
we have the number of police officers today, they are the ones
that's budgeted about 35,000 headcount. And I think the key thing
is that we have to make it easier for police to focus on police
work, not ask them to respond to 200,000 mental health calls
a year. >> So is that a reduction from what you're at right
now? Are you committing to maintaining the same levels?
>> I've committed over the course of the campaign to maintain
the 35,000. That's the headcount that we had through the >> Not
replace them with case workers, social work. >> No, I've
said that's the headcount that we want. What we need to do is
make sure they can focus on serious crime. >> And he just
retained a great police commissioner, I believe. Right. >> Yes.
Yes, we did. Commissioner said, if the newspapers are correct,
>> that one they're correct about. >> He uh he retained
I think somebody that is a >> he's a good friend of some
of the people in my family of Ivanka and they say she's really
good. >> Sorry, I just need to make sure I'm paying full
attention
and he just retained her. So, that's a good sign.
>> Topics that you see agreeing on in the future and do
you think you'll have more >> There will be topics that
we disagree on. I think we'll probably come to a conclusion and
uh ultimately
he'll convince me or can
>> uh hold on. The funniest thing in the world is that
he reverses on Mani 360 and now asks Mani to call him a fascist.
Reverses 360 and now asks Mandani to call him a fascist. But
Mani's policy suggestion here is not good on the property tax
changes.
Um wait, why is it not good? Hold on. PJ forehead. I understand
that people might not like the property tax changes, but I do
think this is one thing where maybe stuff should change or you
should have redistribution of property taxes throughout the city
for education,
right? I think I think the issue Yeah, reverses 180. But I think
the issue with property taxes is you have no property taxes connected
like collected from in the hood, right? And so the public schools
in the hood suck like instantly. like they they just automatically
suck. And I think you need to redistribute some of those property
taxes, at least with regards to how they're allocated to schools
so that you don't have the education in the in the poorest neighborhoods,
right? There needs to be some rubber rubber banding effect going
on.
So maybe he's saying we need to tax more. I think redistribution
is a better idea, like a better thing to do. But I would imagine
there's some amount of redistribution going on because you say
you tax more, but obviously that tax that tax burden has to be
like redistributed because I think the burrows with property
taxes I think they do it by themselves
essentially from what I understand in places like New York your
schools are funded by your property taxes and there's some like
proximity factor there that was what I understood it to be >> offense
him you know it's for the good of New York ultimately it's for
the good of New York I don't care about
affiliations or parties or anything else I want to see if this
city could be unbelievable if he could be a spectacular success.
I'd be very happy. >> you think you guys will meet more
in the
>> Do you think you'll meet again in the future? You have
to >> I think we will. Yeah, I think we will >> nationwide.
That's how it works. Yeah, but I don't understand cuz property
taxes would have to go to the city and you'd think the city could
like themselves handle that.
Yeah, but like the city could redistribute you the taxes. You
would think I understand that they go by district or something.
I just think Yeah, you have to have some way of redistributing
them to be honest.
for for education specifically. Maybe not for other stuff like
obviously higher cost of living areas. You would want them to
have like good things there because they are paying more. But
somehow there's got to be something there, a little provision
for education that we're going to take a little bit out of these
public areas or to put it to some other public areas. But then
in the States, you guys have private schools, which makes no
sense to me. Okay. I don't I don't know. Do we have that in Canada?
I can't think of like a private school anywhere around me. There
must be private schools, but I don't know how private education
even works in Canada. Um, like I didn't have any private schools
around me, but I didn't live in a high cost of living area. I
didn't live in a like rich area. Like
>> I'm guessing I went to private school as a kid. Here's
why they exist. Religion. Yeah, but there's a different there's
a different school system where I live that is just for religious
schools.
like they're I believe they're still through
like the government, but they're just religious schools. Religious
schools have like a different curriculum. They have to do their
own curriculum, but I think it's all managed like under the government.
We have charter schools, too. Okay. I didn't know that. That's
Maybe maybe the religious schools are all handled as charter
schools and I've just never looked into it cuz I didn't I went
to public school my whole life. >> we do. I enjoyed the
meeting. We had a great meeting. Please, >> Mr. President.
Republican Alisa Stefanic has campaigned multiple times by calling
Zora Mandani a jihadist. Do you think >> you said that
as mayor you'd be keeping on NYPD commission? >> No, I
know. But uh she's out there campaigning and uh you know >> Oh,
so Lee Stefonic. Is that your opinion, Mr. Trump? Elise Stefonic
is an
>> You say things sometimes in a campaign.
>> She's a very capable person,
>> but uh you you really have to ask her about that. But
I don't particular I think I met with a very I I met with a man
who's a very rational person. I met with a man who wants to see
really wants to see New York be great again. And I can say again
because New York was great. You know when I came down to Washington
initially
uh the city was so hot. It was doing great. Uh we were some having
some telltale signs of problems. We had a mayor that was not
doing a great job, but still it was moving along. And uh
>> to be fair, at least Stefaniac is actually Stefanic
is actually a like a total [__] So
it's very funny that
she's based so much of her campaign stuff on
I guess focusing on like anti-semitism.
She's she's been like majorly focused on it to the point that
the Twitch anti-semitism stuff they were starting to rely on
at least Stefonic making statements on their behalf. It's like
why are you relying on somebody Trump considered for vice president
to to like or get rid of racism movement. Doesn't that seem stupid?
>> It went bad. It really went, you know, pretty bad. And
he can I think it's been at lower points, but it it went pretty
bad. I think he can bring it back. Now the question is, will
he bring it back all the way? Will will he bring it back greater
than ever before? Which is I guarantee that's his wish. I think
he wants to make it greater than ever
>> And if he can, we'll be out there cheering. I'll be
cheering for him. Thank Thank you very much, everybody.
>> Yeah, Trump
Trump must actually like this guy. I I thought it'd be like a
little performative, but he does. He Trump was in rare form here.
You don't see this a lot from Trump in the modern day. Maybe
maybe he like actually was just sick. Maybe he had like mono
or something. Dude, he he was so low energy for months. And for
some reason in this interview, he's like he's at least 2020 Trump.
At least. Okay, he's not 2016 Trump. That's a different guy.
That guy's never coming back. But he was like at least 2020 Trump
here.
The attention energizes him. Viviance, you dummy. He's on drugs.
Maybe he's on drugs. He should keep taking the drugs. The drugs
are helping a lot.
>> Thank you very much. >> No, I I I care very deeply
about Jewish safety and I look forward to rooting out anti-mitism
across >> Oh, very look see this is Zoron has actually
Zoron knows that there's no reason to to be against this. It's
like, hey, there's this racism that's prevalent. We're scared
about it. Zoron should never ever just because you think, you
know, anti-semitism is used as a weapon to to prevent people
from saying certain things or or doing certain things that are
anti-Israel. Just because you think it's a weapon doesn't mean
you should ever go, "Yeah, I fully support anti-semitism, right?"
You should always be against it.
Must someone always ask him the anti-semitism question. Well,
he just he doesn't flub it. They keep thinking he's going to
flub it, but he's not going to flub it. I'm against racism. It's
not a hard position to have as a politician. Okay? In fact, it's
the it's the position you probably should have. It's not difficult.
It's Yeah, I'm against racism. If there's racism happening, we're
going to get rid of it. That's my I'm committed to being not
racist
unless it's white neighborhoods. Okay. >> Across the five
burrows and protecting Jewish New Yorkers and every New Yorker
who calls city home.
>> I think one took over. How should I put this? When I've
watched Zoron speak, it's not been great. Okay. But I've mostly
been watching him in response to fairly uncomfortable questioning.
I've not watched a ton of like his own free form speeches and
stuff.
I think there have been good moments that I've seen, but he he
sometimes I don't know there's there's a
he goes from the working-class populism to the like progressive
I don't I want to call it tanky like the Tik Tok type of leftism
where he's like talking about race. He's talking about oppression
in a way that's like kind of weird and I don't like and I think
it's away from like the working-class populism message. This
isn't really a problem cuz he's in New York City. If he was running
as a national candidate, I would have like different notes. But
in New York City, it's like whatever. You can you can kind of
say this and not really have be that big a deal. There's not
going to be like a ton of like most of the white people in New
York are pretty progressive. You don't see that at all? Well,
I think the the taxing white people, Matt, you weren't you weren't
here, but we watched the the clip of him and him responding to
the policy about taxing white neighborhoods. I just think if
if whiteness is not a part of the factors of how you're determining
the policy, why mention it? Like this the idea that it's just
descriptive, you can say that, but then there are a bunch of
other areas where actual racists use descriptions
to
to like forward like racist notions, racist ideas, right?
And some of these can be positive to virtue signal. So that's
my thing is like it's the same as it's not quite as bad obviously,
but it's the same as somebody doing the 1352 or 1350 thing, right?
It's like that is a description of reality, but why are you saying
that? Why are you using that description of reality right now?
And if you can't tell me why, if you just tell me that it's descriptive,
so it's okay,
I'm concerned. You should have a good idea.
You should have a very good idea of why you're using that. If
you don't and it's like possibly like a stereotype or possibly
being like, you know, some racial targeting element is going
on there. Yes, I understand that. Aon Lord Arch, but then why
didn't he just say
If if it's only about how some rich neighborhoods aren't paying
enough, then why did he say rich white neighborhoods? Why would
he talk about okay, if there's crime going on in black neighborhoods,
would he say we need to crack down on these blacker neighborhoods?
Would he do
Obviously not. Obviously no. Right.
There is there is no issue here where you have to use like the
the racial bit if it's not a part of your targeting. So either
it's a part of something that you're concerned about whiteness
or and it's it's a part of the policy so it has to be said or
it's just descriptive and
and you need to tell me why. I I guess just tell me why. You
you can't just say it's descriptive. That's not an escape hatch
here. There's a reason cuz he's a dumb progressive who can't
shut it off when he needs to. I mean,
okay, that's fine. Somebody wrote it on his website. I'm just
saying that if you're going to say it, you should know why you're
saying it. Elsewise, you're going to let your opponents define
why you're saying it. You cannot just say it's a description.
And at some point, he's going to get a reporter who has like
a thousand more brain cells than the two that Jack Basobic has,
right?
And he's going to get pressed on that and he's going to look
stupid. He will look stupid. you could easily press him on this
and he would look dumb. Now, Jack Pacovic luckily went, "Uh,
is it your intent to tax white people?" And Zor goes, "That's
not the intent." He goes, "Uh, so it's your intent then." No,
that's not the intent. Uh, but I think it's your intent, actually.
Uh, I think it's your intent, actually. Did you watch his answer
to Jack? Yeah, Jack is a Jack didn't press in any way that made
sense or could be held against him at all. But eventually he's
going to find a who's going to ask him about it and actually
want to press him on it and then he's going to be in trouble.
Jack is just so he's he's lucky that Jack was there and and couldn't
do anything.
Very
Benny Johnson praised Jack on that question. Well, if that's
not indicative,
listen, least least
surprising statement ever uttered. Benny Johnson praised Jack
Bopic on doing something totally Yeah, of course. Yeah, that
sounds about right. Sounds like what would happen?
Good lord.
Hey boy. All right.
Are we going to do MTG? We're going to do large march in charge.
I think we should do MTG here.
Oh. Oh, I like this tweet though. This is a funny tweet. This
is Trump the next day. Trump the next day is like looking like
this. He meets with mom Donnie one time and immediately tries
to step up his step his swag up. That's funny. It's like a weird
look. It's like not bad. I like the coat. I've got I've got basically
this coat. You know, these coats almost always look good.
It It's just a weird look for Trump.
Not a Trump look. Oh, pull up the Lum React. Hold on. I think
Kger was telling me he had the
Okay, hold on. Let's look at the Lum React. Apparently, this
is on r/ Destiny. Let's check it out. Wild to allow jihadist
communist to stand behind the president's desk in the Oval Office.
Sad to see transhumanist jihadist or transhumanist jihad.
It would be nice to see the admin not give Mani a total pass
for his support of Islamic terrorism and his incitement of violence,
his incitement of hatred, sorry, against white people and non-Muslims.
We need to see some moral clarity on the issues of anti-white
racism and normalization of Islamic supremacy from the GOP.
Wait, what?
>> Wait, what? Huh?
What? I don't know where the Islamic supremacy thing comes from.
Listen, I I could believe
I could believe that Zora Mandani is a little bit racist. I happen
to think most people are a little bit racist. He might not like
white people. If you had the option of a non-racist politician,
you should vote for that. But for everybody else who lives in
the real world, you're usually voting against one voting for
one racist over a different kind of racist. That just tends to
be the way it is.
Trump has called Mdani a communist and posted my report about
how Mdani campaigned with a 1993 World Trade Center bombing suspect.
He was backed by and the Muslim Brotherhood. Why is he this not
being called out by the Trump admin? It's very dangerous to our
Okay. Um,
[__] Oh, I'm so lucky I still haven't plugged my
soundboard in cuz I definitely want to play the song right now.
I want to play the song so badly. Laura Loomer.
I find it funny that Laura Loomer is like so obviously getting
paid. Maybe not even getting I don't know. She's so obviously
like a Zionist shill, but she was also friends with Nick Fentes.
It's like why was she friends with Nick Fentes? Why was she trying
to cozy up to him like 3 years ago? What was going on there?
Not condemning Trump. However, I think we can all agree it's
a bad look to let a foreignb born jihadist who said he WANTS
TO IMPLEMENT ANTI-WHITE policies like taxing white people more
money to stand behind the desk in the Oval Office.
Um,
yeah, I can't get over how stupid this policy was to put into
place or to have written down this way.
What was it? Even the rep Let me just put it this way. If you
are doing any kind of racial targeting, even the Republicans
know not to put it out there in public. Okay? How stupid are
you to think that you could just put any like any racially targeted
policy in your campaign platform, anything, right?
How how can you do that? I have no clue where that comes from.
We watched it earlier, PJ Forehead. We We watched it earlier.
Give me a second. I can pull up the clip for you and you can
watch it on your own if you like, but we we just watched it,
so I'm probably not going to watch it again. Essentially, he
says, "No, no, no. We're not targeting people based on this at
all. We are
we're I'm just describing reality. No, the policy itself. Oh,
the policy itself is just Well, so the policy itself doesn't
exist yet, right? But on his website, he's got a quote where
it says we're going to tax the richer and whiter neighborhoods
more. The richer, whiter neighborhoods more. That's there's no
like policy written down. There's no extreme
extremely detailed policy written down. Again, it's
it's very very different
Xanakali
like you could say targeting white areas. It's ultimately it
is about the economics, right? The same thing with the gerrymandering.
It's like yeah, it happens to be along racial lines, but realistically
if black people voted for them, they'd get those they'd get way
different lines for gerrymandering, right? It's not a race-based
issue. It is a voting based issue. That's that's where so it
correlates, but it isn't causal in any way. And that's really
what they're trying to do with the Supreme Court is is figure
out whether it's causal or not. Anyway, we continue.
We continue. We continue. Where is she going here? Mani said
America is a racist country and he supports communists who say
white men are the most evil people in our country. He calls Trump
supporters fascists and incites violence against every day. I
Why do you tie these things together? Like I I can't tell you
how clear I am on proionist propaganda. He calls Trump supporters
fascist. This is very bad. This is what St. Charlie and incites
violence against every day. Um, one proof, two proof, three proof.
Wait, why are you trying to tie these things
I don't get it. I do get it, but it's like so obvious. It doesn't
work. It literally doesn't work. It doesn't work
Yeah, we played that video on stream like eight different times,
Radical Rob. Yeah, we we we play that video all the time. She's
she's a goof. Okay.
But all I see now is somebody who's like an asset. Okay. Radical
Rob. What I see is not somebody who is a embarrassing
drunken loser. Now I see like a an
like an actual asset who is trying to get in with a white nationalist
movement as a source of intelligence. I'm not joking. Like I
in my mind I'm like is that what was actually happening there?
Do you know what I mean?
Cuz cuz it's just so overt. It's so overt now. God, I'm becoming
like totally conspiracy pill. This [__] up. So, this
means we aren't getting mass deportations in NYC. I took Trump
at his word when he said he wasn't giving Mumani funding. Now,
he said he's working with him one day after Mani supporters stormed
a synagogue in NYC and called for the for to be murdered. Mani
said he will fight all Trump policies. His election night speech
was dedicated to getting Trump. Are we normalizing? Wait, what?
I didn't think his his election night speech was dedicated to
getting Trump.
That's not true. I watch that. I I praise Maldani for being focused
on New York City issues and dodging the other stuff, the noise,
right? He dodged a lot of the Israel stuff. He dodged a lot of
the oh, Trump's threatening you stuff. Like, he just I think
he just said like, "We'll we'll find a way to work with the president."
I I don't think he tried to
he leaned into it. Well, in his defense, Trump was talking about
cutting all federal funding in New York City. And I do think
Trump was also talking about raiding New York City with ICE.
That is something you should fight against though, right? Like
like I'm sorry, the the ICE thing you do have to lean into, but
that's resisting ICE. Yeah, banning. Okay. Trump said he's withholding
aid. I guess that's not happening. Wait, wait, wait. Uh, are
we normalizing communism now? It's quite remarkable. What are
we doing? Trump said he's withholding aid. I guess that's not
happening. M Donnie said he's banning ICE from operating at NYC.
I guess this also means we won't be seeing the DOJ review Zoron
Kani's lies on his immigration paperwork. The GOP talked a big
talk about having Pam Bondi look at denaturalizing look into
denaturalizing Mandani.
Jesus Christ.
But it was just a publicity stunt by GOP congressman. Uh it looks
like it was just a geo a publicity stunt.
Dude, talk about denaturalizing people. So gross. I You have
to work with the people in your country regardless of what they
think. Don't try to take away people's citizenship every time
they disagree with you. Oh boy. Okay.
Trump just said Mamani is rational. There's nothing rational
about allowing criminal illegal aliens to terrorize New York
City. I'm stunned. Hopefully, we see more of a condemnation of
Mandani and his communist anti-white and jihadist views from
the pres from President Trump. This is very dangerous. We can
address affordability without embracing anti-white racism and
communism. What are we doing?
You think,
dude?
I'm sorry. I also guarantee you that Mum Donnie walked into that
meeting and went, "Hey, just so you know, here's some things
like people say about me." And but I'm just like you, Mr. Trump.
I The media is just like they are the way they are with you.
That's how they are with me. You wouldn't even know what my positions
are cuz they just make things up about me. And he probably would
have had examples. I'm guessing like if Trump was like, "Oh,
I'd heard this about you. Bombi would have answers to those questions.
Oh, I heard you're like a jihadist. No, we're going to take care
of anti-semitism. We won't don't want to see any of our residents
hurt." Obviously,
right? Trump threatens to cut funds if communist Mumdani wins
mayoral election. She just posts the the title. Laura, are you
condemning President Trump for allowing Zoran Mumani to stand
behind this uh his desk?
Uh here's just a picture of a title Guardian article.
Just stand on business, Laura. Don't be a Don't be a [__]
Stand on business.
Montani openly campaigned with Palestinians who stormed synagogues.
He campaigned with a 1993 World Trade Center bombing co-conspirator.
Montani said, "Globalize the inifata." Montani wants white people
to be taxed more. Montani wants to ban ICE. What part of any
of that makes anyone feel comfortable? Um, I mean, I would want
a better answer on this one personally, but it's like so lowgrade.
It's like I could even if that was his policy, I'd still vote
for him, right? Even if that was even if he was just like, I
think we're going to racially t people for taxes. Even that if
that was his policy, I'd probably still think about voting for
him.
Right? Assuming assuming it's not crazy. Like obviously it can't
be too crazy. The laugher curve exists, right? It can't be that
insane, but if it was just like we're going to bump this up a
little more and white is approximately like approximately correlates
with who could pay more in taxes, so we're going to tax them
more. I'd be like, oh, maybe I'd like to see exceptions for like
poor white people, I guess. But if you're if you're Yeah. The
thing is you can't even you can't even make sense of like targeting
people based on race. I'm like trying to think of this entire
concept to me is so low grade compared to so many other things
that I just can't really care about it. I shouldn't say if he
targeted if he if he came out and was like our number one policy
is taxing white people out of New York City obviously wouldn't
vote for him but that wouldn't be what it is and it's not what
it is.
So it's just it's like so below all the other stuff. Wants to
ban ICE. Yeah, people don't like you know militias rolling through
their cities beating up minorities. Turns out
uh the 1993 World Trade Center bombing co-conspirator. I'd have
to look into this more. I don't know what this one is. Globalize
the antifata. We know is in fact I believe it's true that he
did not even say globalize the antifata,
right? Am I am I right or wrong on this?
I'm pretty confident he didn't even say globalize the inifata.
He like quoted somebody saying it or something. Didn't like disavow
it. Uh, what is G the GOP going to campaign on ahead of the midterms
if the GOP is saying Mdani is good? They're not saying he's good.
He had a meeting with Trump. Trump's had positive meetings. Why
didn't she freak out like this when it was when
when Trump had meetings with Kim Jong-un and Kim Jong-un spoke
favorably of him and Trump spoke favorably of him? Why weren't
people on the right melting down like that? Right? Mel melting
down like this. Trump literally belates
total authoritarian like the most vile authoritarian people on
the authoritarian people on the planet and it doesn't matter
but now he's like oh I can work with this guy in New York City
and that is the end of the world
bro here's pop quiz for Laura Loomer pop quiz because I think
I know the answer do you think dislikes people more Laura
MBS
or Zora Mandani
just quick Quick pop quiz.
Who do you think hates more? Cuz I know the answer. I know you
know the answer. Were you freaking out like this when when Trump
meets with NBS and is like, "Yeah, this guy's awesome. We're
going to get him some some Nvidia chips. We're going to jump
start their AI program." Okay. She's right that it undercuts
GOP election strategy. Well, I mean GOP election strategy is
red scare,
but I don't know if the if the red scare works on somebody like
this.
I don't know if it works in New York City, obviously.
Like the GOP didn't really have a solid candidate running against
Mum Donnie.
I don't know. We'll see. Let's see. Where else are we going from
here? What is the GOP going to campaign on? This is very bad
for our politics.
He's still the same Mani. This is very bad for a country to normalize
Mdani's policies polices. Trump said Mdani is a communist who
will destroy New York. He is still the same. Nothing about any
of that should make anyone feel comfortable. It's going to be
a disaster. You'll see.
Globalized antifata doesn't matter to New York City. 1993 World
Trade Center bombing co-conspirator. I mean, that kind of maybe
matters a little bit. Campaigned with Palestinians who stormed
synagogues. Again, I don't think this matters to most of New
York City. You're describing things that matter to a subset of
New Yorkers. And he's committed to rooting out anti-semitism
and not letting it fester in the city.
this one I think is his worst one. Uh, I think most people are
behind banning ICE. Most people don't want a militia of redneck
walking down the street shooting people. Um,
yeah. Shooting people, detaining people for no reason. Most people
just don't want that. They're like, "Oh, actually, this is worse
than the immigrants.
That's just most people." So, she's describing a bunch of issues
that are her issues, but they're not New Yorker issues at all.
Uh, this Mom Donnie Trump press conference is an absolute bromance.
Both guys seem to love each other. Almost zero conflict, tons
of praise for each other. So, are we just going to normalize
communism? Aren't you the a host of conservative radio program?
Clay Travis, what are you preserving by glazing communism, anti-white
racism, hatred, open borders, and Islamic terror? Hey, Laura,
have you not seen that? Like, I'm sorry, I feel like glazing
hatred is what you participated in by being one of New York,
sorry, one of Nick Fentes's closest confidants for a long time.
She literally used to buddy buddy be buddy buddy with Nick all
the time.
How is Zoron more o overtly hateful of than Nick is? That's crazy.
Sad to see GOP will lose the midterms. Well, that's not that's
obvious, but to do with different stuff.
Why did President Zalinski
receive a harsher welcome at the White House than Mandani? Interesting.
If socialists are doing a good job, then I guess nobody needs
to vote them out during the midterms.
Well, is Mani even like sworn in his mayor yet? Is he actually
the mayor yet? I actually don't know. I just feel like he's he's
probably not even the mayor yet. No. Yeah. So, he's not even
doing a good job or bad job. If you're a Republican, why not
just stay home in 2026 and 2028 since Mani's policies are amazing.
I'm confused. No need to oppose the left. I guess
uh there's obviously like a way different thing going on here.
By the way, there's something that we all understand, we all
get, and that's this. Okay. On a localized level, everybody is
more charitable. Everybody is more willing to stomach like my
taxes going to help people in my community if it helps them.
I'm okay with that. My taxes going to blowing up somebody in
the Middle East, bad. My taxes going to helping a drug addict
get off of drugs and get a job so they're not a homeless bum
on the street. Good. Okay, these are entirely different concepts.
You [__]
So don't be shocked when somebody is like, "Oh, this guy wants
to take care of New York City. He thinks he could reroute taxes
to to do a more or do like a better job of that." Yeah, I'll
vote for that.
Yeah, my tax is going to bailing out Argentina. That okay, my
taxes going to bailing out, you know, my kids school because
they actually overcommitted to purchasing something to make their
lives better. Oh, based. I love that.
My money going outside of New York City, bad. My money being
used to make New York City residents lives better, good. This
might be true, Lui. I maybe picked the wrong example. That's
probably the one example conservatives would never be behind.
But the grocery stores, I think the grocery stores would be good.
I do think the grocery stores would be
And it's why I'm not feeling better, American Swag, but I took
some drugs and I took some caffeine and we're making it work.
Okay.
But like everybody understands this at in their heart of hearts.
They all understand it, right? Everybody agrees that the broad
concept of like you being a socialist when it comes to your personal
community and a a like harsh libertarian when it comes to people
outside of your country, everybody gets that. It's just tweaking
from there. But yes, even Republicans are willing to pay, you
know, have their prop their property taxes are going to stuff
in their community anyway, right? PJ forehead, yes, governmentr
run enterprise is good. It absolutely does prevent like insane
monopoliz or insane collusion from raising prices on stuff. They
they create a price ceiling and not a price ceiling by like implementing
price ceiling. They they create a price ceiling by engaging in
the market and so the market can't be manipulated. They're willing
to sell things at the correct
Yep. This is absolutely how it works. Yes, that government-run
enterprise is very good when there is collusion going on in a
market. It's why, by the way, Comcast and Cox Cable lobbyed so
hard against any major infrastructure projects anywhere in the
United States to start installing fiber to start installing like
governmentr run internet because they know as long as they have
a monopoly on that, as long as they can collude and run their
monopoly,
they're they they're on easy street. They can name their prices.
They can have a total [__] they could be total [__]
at customer service. Doesn't matter, right?
But you introduce governmentr run internet to something and suddenly
they have a price ceiling. Suddenly they they have to charge
what the market rate is. So I'm a huge fan of governmentr run
enterprise. I'm not like a communist or a socialist, but some
governmentr run enterprises absolutely introduce by participating
in the market price ceilings for things.
And you'll see that when things get rough like during co exactly
like during co okay anywhere where there's governmentr run industries
where they compete in the market you'll always see lower inflation
there because it turns out when when prices are going up everybody
takes their extra 1%. Everybody along the chain takes their extra
1%. Okay. Yeah, things are getting rough. I'm going to charge
a little bit more. Things are getting rough. I'm going to charge
a little bit more. Actually, everybody takes their pound of flesh
and then eventually when it gets to the end consumer, they're
totally
the government can at least do something about that last hop.
Okay. The grocery is not going to grocery store is not going to
take their extra 1 2 3% on something cuz they can just go to
the government one. But they still participate in the same marketplace.
They still have the same margins. They're not great.
Anyway,
continuing
retweeting, Lumor Unleashed, Zoro Donnie lied saying, "I care
deeply about safety and I and look I look forward to rooting
out anti-semitism across the five buraus and protecting New Yorkers
and every New Yorker who calls the city home." This morning when
when we confronted him, Zoramani said something totally different.
Watch. Wait, where's the We need the link to this one. Hold on.
Uh, loomer
god. Hold on. There's a there's a Twitter account called Loomer
Unleashed. Where is this,
bro? There's no way there's a there's no shot that there is a
Loomer Unleashed
Twitter community
that has like Okay, I thought I had tons of activity. It's got
8.1K members, but it's got not that much activity. Never mind.
But it's there's the account Lum Unleashed.
Where is this? Where did Zoron say this? Going to look for it.
Right here.
I'm your support. So, as he landed in DC moments ago for his
meeting with President Trump today at Loomer, Charles DS confronted
Zoro Mamani and asked him if he condemns his supporters who violently
stormed a synagogue last night in NYC where Mani supporters called
for Why are they Mumani supporters? Were they like wearing the
shirts?
Were they like rocking the branding to go and attack this synagogue
or something? How do you know they're Mandani supporters? >> Will
you condemn your supporters for harassing outside New York City
>> Oops. You're not going to You're not going to condemn
your supporters for harassing Mr.
>> The supporters that I have are the ones. >> Are
you nervous?
>> Those aren't my supporters is the
>> What's thating? Mr. Zan,
>> Mr. Zoron, do you condemn anti-semitism in all of its
forms? Master Zoron,
Zoron, do you condemn anti- will you condemn your supporters
who attack the
Zoran, Mr. Come on, Donnie. >> Orders that I have are the
ones focused on the portability. >> Are you nervous? >> Okay.
All right. Yes. This is the clip.
We are witnesses the witnesses. We are witnessing probably the
stages of what will become a pagram if leadership isn't exercised
immediately. [laughter] What? What can I see? Can we see the
synagogue attack that happened? This would be yesterday, right?
Um let me let me go try to find the synagogue attack. Let's see
what it is. NYC synagogue
protest. Anti-ionist protesters chant death to the IDF at New
York City synagogue.
Anti-ionist protesters chanted for an inifatada and heckled at
demon at demonstration outside a prominent New York City synagogue
on Wednesday night. The demonstrators gathered outside the Park
East Synagogue in Manhattan to protest against an event held
by Nefesh Ben Nephesh Nefesh Bunesh,
an organization that helps Jews immigrate to Israel. Around 200
demonstrators chanted, "Death to the IDF. We don't want no Zionist
here." And resistance,
"Resistance, you make us proud. Take another settler out."
Dude, these are really convoluted.
Resistance, make us proud. Take another settler.
I This is not rhyming. This sucks. I do think this is
Is this like an organization that sets you up if you're like
an American Jew? If you like want land in some settlement, is
this like one of those organizations? Cuz I remember we watched
one of the documentaries. Maybe it was the Louis Theorough documentary.
I can't remember. We watched a documentary and it's like, "Yeah,
I came from New York City and they just set me up with this like
plot of land."
Memorize that name. He's running for office somewhere in New
York City. Hold on.
This is an organization.
This doesn't say it's a person. It's an organization. Where's
the name? Hold on. Hold. What is this?
>> It'll just be your baby. >> Hold on. Hold on.
Reuben Ruben donated $3. Wait, are they threatening our favorite
podcasters? Uh, wife. >> True. I didn't think about it.
Thank you, Reuben. Ruben, these are direct threats. Listen, support
for Ela Klein is pivotal right now. Okay. Very important. We
support Hila Klein. These vile attacks against her. Death to
the IDF. Does that mean anybody who's ever been in the IDF? And
does that mean Ethan Klein's wife? Excuse me. Are you calling
for the death of Ethan Klein's wife right now?
I understand that. Oh, look. It's the protesters.
The Orthodox guys are back. Judaism condemns the state of Israel
and its atrocities. These guys are everywhere in New York City.
If there's ever a protest against people at a synagogue in New
York City, these guys are there. They're ready to go.
Hey, they hate every other person who supports Israel.
Those are the Mamani supporters, I guess. Well, to be fair, Sneo
ran into these guys outside of Mani's victory like party or whatever.
>> It's really rough for people though and Israel in general
that death death to the IDF is so catchy. I'm sorry, but if I
was like in that crowd, I would be humming this. I'd find myself
like singing it randomly in random places. Okay, it would be
very awkward. You're like in the grocery line
death.
You just be doing it. It's like catchy. It just catches on.
It sucks cuz I don't want I don't want people to feel unsafe,
but
Damn. It's just catchy. All of these All of these are catchy.
Okay, we got to go back to this threat. And then Kger said it
it cuts off before we're done with this. I need some water really
quickly as well. So, I'll be right back. Let me put something
on to not lose the momentum here. What was Trump saying? Got
to look for Trump today. Watch this. We're going to Andrew's
Air Force B to do some work especially for our great air force.
We're doing some fix up of the base with the team. We're going
to try and reinstitute
the golf course for meeting with the great Jack Nicholas.
>> We're going to Andrew Air Force B. >> Okay, I'm
back. He's meeting with Jack Nicholas. Dude, he's got to stop
doing interviews only outside of his plane or they have to figure
something out with the mics. I there has to be some way you can
sound engineer this so that your voice comes through over the
mics, right? Or sorry, over the um over the airplane is crazy.
Trump can't pull that look off. That is not the look for Trump,
I don't think. I feel like somebody convinced him to do this
and now he's getting blown up for it. Okay, you see Trump hearing
about previous Brazil president getting arrested. Nope.
Nope. Nope. Nope.
Get back to Oh, hold on. We're still doing Laura Loomer stuff.
Let's [clears throat] keep looking.
We watch
America's future doesn't look so bright. I'm not optimistic about
what our country will look like in 2030. I'm going to be very
honest. We have a lot of problems and we only have less than
a year to address them before Dems take the house. I'm I'm not
an optimist. I'm a realist. Okay, hold on. Apparently, there
are more things here.
God damn.
Hold on. Hold on.
An imager. Dude, what's the point of even having a VPN if every
site just cut the VPN automatically? What is the point? Okay,
we continue on from here. What is Elise Stefonic going to campaign
on now during her NY governatorial campaign since Zoro and Kam
Donniey's policies have been signed off as comfy by the GOP?
Are you still running for governor? Elise Dems just need to run
clips of the presser today to defeat Elise. Ooh.
Ooh. Ooh.
Elise Stef Well, that's probably good. Stefanic sucks.
Could Stefanic really win in New York? I feel like there's no
way she could win. Like, Stefonic just sucks. I don't want to
hear another conservative ever complain again about being called
a fascist. If we're going to be outraged, let it be real. We
should mind the word fascist is what got
[laughter]
I don't mind. Call me a fascist. No, that's what St. Charlie.
That's what That's what they got St. Charlie for.
No, you can't say it. No. No,
you can't say fascist. Okay.
Anyway, that's the that's the loomer stuff. It's all the loomer
stuff. Dude, I want to tweet out about like Zoron's smile. Somebody
has to have pointed this out, right? That Zoron's doing like
a fake smile. He never smiles like this.
I maybe after stream I'll put together like a tweet. I'll get
all the evidence. Okay. I'll get all the evidence for Zoron's
like little inside joke at Trump's expense.